ladies and gentlemen
i stand before you
by the grace of god
i am in terrible shape i'm just looking
at myself in the preview of how red my
face looks
for those of you that jesus
that is one block you looking dome
yeah uh
if you missed on friday i started having
a live
allergic reaction to something
and this weekend was brutal man i think
it looks better than it did
i mean on saturday the weekend was was
peak
messed up
but uh it's itchy and i hate to say this
but like my nether regions is
so bad and it's so itchy and it's just
my face
and my ween
and uh you know it's kind of
embarrassing too because i'm constantly
itching my myself
and it looks like i'm playing with
myself
it's one of the advantages really yeah i
get away with it there's no way i could
i could touch myself in any meaningful
way right now you know what i mean
it's all just pain bummer
i know
i think you got to go to the doctor i
don't know i need to see a medical
professional
i don't know about that
well we appreciate still coming out
no it is it is getting better i'm
telling you on the weekend it was even
more messed up okay because it
definitely it looks significantly worse
than it did on friday well i shaved off
the first thing i did is i went home and
shaved off the beard
so i could see the damage
i've just i've never had an allergic
reaction before so the whole thing is
pretty baffling to me
and even after like reflecting you can't
think of any uh i mean the only thing is
the soap but like you tell me what you
think about the soap i used this soap
many times before
it sat dormant for like two years for
some reason i busted it out used it on
my beard
the night before because i mean can soap
go bad i don't know i i don't i don't i
have no idea but like
it just seems odd that i've used it
before and then i it soap doesn't strike
me as something that can go bad
soap can expire
does it make you
oh we have
[Laughter]
i was just looking at our thumbnail we
have mr beast and elon
[Applause]
spicy
beautiful
yeah you know
i'm not i'm not gonna sit here and be a
proud man before you but i also sharted
you told me you weren't gonna share that
i know but i have to share everything on
there i knew
just last night
sitting there all
blotched up and
sad and i've also been on benadryl so
i've just been like sleeping all the
time and like in a in a
state of semi-consciousness
wake up put on some cream pass out [ __ ]
myself
eat some food
it's been fun
but it's monday's issue tv you know i'm
getting coming here boy
lots of people saying that soap
definitely goes bad so but can it give
you an allergic really i just feel yeah
yeah okay so then it was the soap it was
like it was the soap i threw it out i
will not be using that again with peace
and love
and yeah i mean
the irony of using a soap that makes
your face explode
um
anyway atlantis would be so proud
who would be proud alainis oh isn't it
ironic
isn't it ironic
when you just [ __ ] your pants oh how
about this
just got out of the shower
and i just [ __ ] my pants
that's what happened
so ironic so much pain coming from my
face
it's a red hue
it's a red hue
on a blue
day it's like taking benadryl
when you're already late now i'm
snoozing in the car
and i crashed on the side
who would have thought it caused rectal
bleeding yeah
i'm trying to be ironic
yeah
well you know what you're here this is
going to be like when jordan played with
food poisoning people will talk about
this day for years to come boo jordan
michael jordan he played with food
poisoning so he did yeah
and did he [ __ ] himself
i
no he held it well how did people know
he had food poisoning what was all that
hype about
uh he was he was pretty messed up i mean
you could see it you could see it and
just his performance yeah it wasn't
people didn't think he had food
poisoning people just thought he was
sick right
it's only because you've watched uh the
last dance five thousand times that you
uh i watch because that was the
revelation in that documentary you
watched that documentary so more than
once i keep it on luke aby puts it on
the tv
every day in the studio well you've
actually stopped because we started
making fun of you do you love that i
heard it's good i haven't it is really
good it's really good i don't even watch
basketball but i love it but he just
happened on his like background noise
that that inspired you to like
inspire you to do something right amy if
it wasn't for that documentary i want to
have this job today i'll say that
wow it's done so much for you
what about me
michael jordan obviously you yeah
directly you but
like five percent michael jordan was it
a playoff game or something i think it
was so this is my this is my food
poisoning day
yeah games four and five in salt lake
city utah
um anyway thank you to quip me undies
and hellofresh
we got a great show today as usual you
know what what it is
got the benadryl coming
i i wonder do i need to keep taking
benadryl that's you should go
well in the absence of a doctor i don't
i mean has the benadryl helped at any
point i think so it's hard to tell but
you know but i think it like reduces the
itching of stuff right now i'm very
itchy
violet you're turning violet violet
you don't have to stop telling me to see
a doctor dan you keep like you're asking
for like advice from a bunch of
dumbasses back here yeah i want chat to
tell me give me medical advice oh yeah
that's even out of med school i know
what i'm talking about here
let's do a poll
ethan's face looks great someone said
no
ethan go to a doctor block him
no i'm kidding i'm fine you guys it's
just a little rash it's fine
you're good bro everyone wants me to see
a doctor guys
it's just a rash the doctor's not going
to do anything
i bend enough times to the doctor they
just say hey put a little [ __ ] thing
on it huh
here's some the doctors go here's some
motrin
it's extra stink ibuprofen to make you
think i did something for you even
though you can buy this [ __ ] from any
pharmacy
i think that you have some kind of
contact dermatitis that actually can be
healed pretty quickly with some cream
tbh
but we won't know unless you try
well here if you think cream will
if you think cream
will fix me then explain this
this is what i was all weekend
looking good
that is a mixture of moisturizer
aloe
vera and uh and that one anti-itch cream
what is it
hydrocortisone
and hemorrha and anal
advanced anal bleeding gold bond just
kind of mixed in there for good measure
here is a side by side of me and chewy
little joker ask
maybe joker just had allergies
what if joker had allergies
beatbox oh
you think that that's
that's why he's so crazy
he's itching
you know our pop-up was over the um
weekend first of all the pop-up was a
huge success honestly thank you guys
everyone who came out
and my sincere apologies to everybody
who didn't make it in there there was
there was more people than we expected
actually and with me and ellis canceling
the signing i thought maybe there'd be
less people
we were kind of afraid no one would be
there to be honest
but there was lots of people there and
you know the crew and everyone did an
amazing job you guys all made an
appearance right
popped in for a little bit yeah yeah
yes sir av was working it
too he was working it but you know we
tried it was a really long line and for
some reason it was like the hottest
[ __ ] day
i mean we're in
like mid-november now
and just a freak occurrence happened to
be that day was super hot so we were
passing out water bottles trying to make
sure everyone was hydrated and stuff
like that
but uh i'm very sorry that people who
waited a long time and didn't get in
that really sucks
and uh i'm very sorry
but to everyone else who got in was was
a lot of fun here i have a little video
here
it was it was a great event you know
we put a lot into it so i'm glad
that
those that got in ha enjoyed it
nice resolution eh
oh that might be my bad
it's like 140 feet damn who shot this
master on a retro camera
to get the right vibe here is this is
this uh your your editing maybe
it is not this is the uh cinematographer
you guys hired oh okay cool yeah so this
is the first time for me seeing watching
videos
[Music]
wow the music's like so very
inspirational yeah
are you guys wanting something funny the
movers when they're removed so these big
statues are those guys none of them
these big statuettes which were sick by
the way how how tall was this bugs bunny
like 12 feet yeah something like that
so warner brother loaned it to us for
the event and the movers uh at the end
of the event we had nothing to do with
it we didn't touch it
[ __ ]
his head fell off
doug's head fell off wait for real yeah
oh no the movers were bringing it back
and they decapitated bugs we had nothing
to do with it with peace and love
it was not us wow
were the movers hired by warner brothers
yeah yeah oh thank god
but i heard that they were all like just
yeah very stressed because these seemed
like
not something you can easily reproduce
nope
i think that may be the last time they
loan these babies out
that's all folks exactly
[Music]
i want to change the song on this piece
of love
[Music]
you don't feeling inspired
no
i think it needs to be more fun than
like this is these are the days we're
going to remember when we're old this is
our town yeah it's our city our time
what does this song tell you it's like
these are the days of our lives
on my deathbed reflecting on it all
[Laughter]
this isn't my first rodeo
yes so okay
interesting
[Laughter]
thank you that's it
here i'll show a photo i didn't make the
cut i wasn't in there
oh you weren't you never got inside it's
[ __ ]
no i'm not on the [ __ ] video oh well
okay dan
but it was really fun i mean we had like
the food was bomb
they were the nails and the spray
painting was super cool here let's see
so here's monty's did you know that
they're fans
monty's yeah yeah
yeah
like the owner of the place no like i
guess whoever was working the food yeah
i like walked up
and she knew my name
hey dan hell yeah dude i'm not alone
i'm not the only one actually i saw a
poster
of your voice cracking like three years
ago and i said dan walked so amy could
run
that's my voice correctly hit him with
that beta zack
but yeah i'm so sorry i'm horrible with
names but the girl recognized us and she
was uh very kind i think her name was
stephanie
i remember
bethany shout out stephanie
yeah
we had a bunch of these statuettes from
warner brothers it was really cool
um
either went there with uh
bella porch
so there was like a thousand people
showed up i guess and
600 got to go through but
a lot of people waited and didn't get in
i'm sad to say
yeah and i i apologize to anyone at the
end who i said i believe you would get
in i was just passing along the message
oh
well i was trying my best to help out
from home but i was like tell just pick
a place in line
and where people you tell them you will
guarantee to get in and everyone else
behind you
won't be able to get in so that people
don't wait
i don't know what exactly went down
though
evie did that everyone saw that but i
saw lots of fan love for abe passing out
water and [ __ ]
it was awesome it was really cool
meeting everyone
yeah so the collection by the way comes
out on this thursday on the website
teddyfresh.com oh yeah the hamburgers we
had a [ __ ] iron dude how sick is that
we made a custom-made uh
branding iron to do on the bun
yep
teddy fresh burger
made with real bear meat actually
no not that well it was vegan
no no it was vegan it's made from black
bears
what's the most uh uh agri yeah whatever
is the most endangered probably grizzly
actually yeah or polar
polar well that's why i was so gamey
polar bear me that was very expensive to
import that
panda
yeah panda
um
are monty's available in la i want
another yeah they're it's a it's a local
um
not really chain i think there's a few
locations in la but yeah it's um yeah
it's an l.a based vegan
uh
burger spot it's called monty's good
burger yep
um
i don't know why these links aren't
working but anyway it was a great time
a great job to the team to put it
together it was a lot of work it was a
big project for us the first one
but i think we're going to look into
getting a permanent uh store so the next
time we do something like this we it's
going to be more than one day everyone's
going to be able to come
yeah i think we're going to do a brick
and mortar store now that's crazy here
in l.a
we're looking at options now
going to go down be down on fairfax with
all the other hypebeasts
i'm not sure we're we're considering a
lot of play you know it was funny we
were looking at rodeo drive
that's like embedded just
curiosity right so rodeo drive is this
shopping place in beverly hills that has
all the super luxury brands like gucci
and chanel yeah
so we we're looking at property there
well chanel bought a building there a
couple years ago
it was 150 million dollars jesus christ
i was like
slightly out of our budget
2 000 square feet
there was another story of some guy that
bought a building there for 50 million
and then approached um there's this one
mega brand that owns like gucci and
louis vuitton and all these
yeah right i forget the name of it but
he approached it to them to
to lease so he paid 50 million for it
the next day he approached them and they
offered him like 110 million to buy it
so he made a one-day
flip
for like 60 million good deal
yeah it's like
did you look i was gonna it's like a
bunch of letters yeah yeah exactly
uh like third fourth richest person in
the world owns that
i remember looking up recently yeah he's
one of the richest absolutely
but anyway i'm proud of the team i'm
proud of ela it was an awesome event and
i'm
very happy people had fun i'm very sorry
that some people didn't get in with
peace and love but if you want to go to
teddyfresh.com the black friday sale
still going on there's lots of stuff to
pick up and this thursday looney tunes
will be out thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
if you want to call in 808 hot meme is
available
we actually share your stories
that's hot seeing all that made me want
to watch some old looney tunes i gotta
figure out where where you can watch
looney tunes nowadays
youtube probably
yeah i don't know they're all on the
boomerang uh streaming service boomerang
yeah is that a joke at boomers
probably the boomers watch yeah maybe
lovebot at 4am
you can fly
that's why the office is so messed up in
the morning i'm wondering what what's
going on that's why it's always not
parked too that's pretty impressive i
gotta say
that was awesome
thank you for that
what is it what is this a b which one
i have it highlighted right here
a b wants me to acknowledge
a photo of his head wrapped what the
[ __ ] does that mean
what
oh [ __ ] yeah dude this girl's hilarious
yo this girl okay [ __ ] first of all
this girl said i drove from arizona to
l.a for the pop-up waited eight hours
and didn't get in i'm very very sorry
i'm so sorry
um but she posted this picture of a b
and what's up with this photo bro
she definitely photoshopped you yeah you
could clearly tell from the wires behind
me
that it is photoshopped i'm not mandark
are you sure
i hope not because sometimes they have
little divots in them the wires
i don't know what i don't know if this
is a tick-tock trend or whatever it is
it is i've seen that photoshop their
friend and see if they notice but she
[ __ ] you up that's
awesome wait let me read the comments
and see if people are saying anything
that ain't a b that's a d
[Laughter]
why does a b look like dan oh come on
that's uncalled for you that's [ __ ] up
why did she photoshop him to look like
that why okay so everybody's seeing it
i think that's hilarious dude ugly
you're disgusting i'm gonna kill you and
then if you look in the dock
i included under that another link
cam help me
uh find the real photo
wait where oh here it is
oh wow you actually went in there okay
so ha ha
here's a b all meaned out and she's got
a big
dome a little revenge for you
i feel redeemed no she was very sweet
did you take you a minute to did you
think this was real for a second or what
like i'm never wearing a beanie again no
i thought it was real when i first saw
it
when you guys sent in the chat what did
she do just increase your dome size i
think she smushed my head and stretched
out the signs this is so funny
this is the best wow so good
love her for this
small update all of looney tunes
is on hbo max and if you'd like to sign
up for hbo right
use her link
shout out
yeah so um
mike magelick and aiden ross admit ethan
was right the klaus house was a failure
wow that's quite a headline
yo the clubhouse is done
mike magic gave up his [ __ ]
well i guess they're back together him
and
right am i following that right who
knows you talking about his girlfriend
or whatever lena or
lana rhodes
on again off again yeah it was hilarious
that mike
left his girlfriend lana rhodes
to start a clout house with faze blanks
and aiden ross basically a scam house if
i'm being honest
like what goes on there other than
shilling gambling to
minors or illegal
uh you know residents of the united
states what actually goes on there okay
and also you guys can live in your own
house and also do illegal [ __ ] like you
don't have to live together to do legal
[ __ ]
if i'm gonna do illegal [ __ ] and make
money i want to at least live nice
before i go to prison you know
i think they'd do more than scam there
was once a murder in that house
keemstar rest in peace
well all right
the clout house was not a failure it was
a massive success by this moment only
this is a w
wow
seconds before tragedy mike is actually
a good guy he did something good
that moment when his girlfriend knew she
needed to get the [ __ ] out of there look
at her face
[Laughter]
when you see your boyfriend get baited
that hard
you gotta go
anyway this is so sad you guys uh the
clown house is gone golly
there's traffic
basically what he's saying is guess what
h3 and trisha payne is oh the content
house didn't work out you were right he
actually didn't give it up that's nice
straight up oh
i thought it was facetious
nope
well what a guy that makes me like it
and i know you're going to cut all this
[ __ ] out but
[Laughter]
basically what he's saying is guess what
h3 and trisha payne is oh the content
house didn't work out you were right you
guys were right you called it the green
curtain remember he called like a crap
what do you say like it was like a
crackhead [ __ ] we weren't all on the
same page
there you go it could have worked aidan
this dream could have been yours
you're a big boy aiden it's time to move
out and be on your own and get a damn
curtain for real
it's kind of interesting to see that you
know my our feedback really uh they
heard it
our our constructive criticism didn't
fall on deaf ears
well some good came out of that house
because it led to the fall
of keem with that video the cringe video
took place there
yeah yeah revealed we just talked about
that for like 10 minutes oh i'm so sorry
i was checking something
i was like what the [ __ ]
maybe you were talking about a different
video
if i'm not listening it's because i'm
watching something out here you're
always three steps ahead two steps
behind
25d chess right now
he's actually in the quantum realm
i'll return shortly
okay [ __ ] it was never even a content
house it was supposed to be a house of
people with like ideas all working
together it is what it is bro all right
if i make this shot uh i'll stay in l.a
if i miss uh i'll go i'm going to new
york so here we go
looked like it was going in listen man
all right cool well enjoy bye
[Applause]
is gambling legal in new york buddy i
don't think so
i don't think so
check out canada maybe
so sad so tragic
no one could have seen this coming
and what aidan's moving to new york i
find that odd
didn't he say he would move to new york
if he made the shot
no he said he would beg out the wrong
way yeah you got it the wrong way
and zach of course predicted zach is our
oracle here in the office he made a
prediction
you know i think i might have [ __ ] my
pants midday
yeah um
zach
always saying mike [ __ ] his gym shorts
and sure enough the day came [ __ ] his
pants ladies and gentlemen well hold on
what was he wearing is he wearing gym
shorts that's the question otherwise
it's an incomplete
uh they might actually be dude gym
shorts oh right
there that might actually be like gym
shorts to be honest
[ __ ] his [ __ ] gym my god
i knew it i i knew it
he's a [ __ ] prophet
i knew it you just gotta give it time
when it comes to fruition
carlos nft so tragic you guys
we love carlos but uh this is just
[ __ ] tragic man after everything
they've been through the redemption arc
is just over
the redemption arc
is over
carlos matos hey everyone the bit
redemption nft collection auction has
been cancelled and all nfts for this
auction will be burned
damn
there was a problem with the smart
contract and also i am no longer going
to be working with the company which was
helping to launch my nfts
there was a problem all right
there's definitely going to be a carlos
matos 2017 big connect annual ceremony
speech nft's collection coming up what
the [ __ ] is that title let me read that
again carlos matos 2017 big connect
annual ceremony speech nft's collection
coming up just rolled off the tongue
in the future stay tuned for future
announcements is this going to be at his
uh his orgy fest or is that a separate
thing
well that might be where he's going to
find the biggest audience for this
so he might just give it to us all of
his concubines
that is at his harem his mind what do
they call it his mind uh
he had a name for it when it's like 20
women and him
his mega mind
thank you am so nfts are like party
favors there
i think the decision to drop them is
your best and your best interest if
you'd like to chat learn more about the
nft market how blockchains work and the
dynamic goes oh we got a new guy moving
in
velcrafting is moving in
vultures let's see if he oh he took the
bait
he took the bait carlos
that sounds like a great idea i'll dm
you soon
this guy hey there legend dm me i have a
proposal all these guys are just trying
to get on our show for sure
and they will
or
scam him well i don't think carlos has
anything left to take that man's lost
everything
i guess he was having a big joke out of
it
carlos i was kind of trying to tell you
what was up yeah he should he should be
thinking yeah i'm here for exposing
yeah i mean
i love that what does this mean by the
way when he says there was a problem
with the smart contract does anyone know
that in the sense
it wasn't that smart
the problem with
with his nft was that it existed at all
the problem that's a cover for something
the problem with the smart contract is
that we didn't own anything
yeah
i love carlos though well
what a story what a saga
the redemption arc what do you think was
he redeemed
do we ever
do we ever share that guy's uh tweets
who's oh my god
we did not the guy that we interviewed
with carlos
oh [ __ ] you really want to go there kind
of i mean it's it's over now i'm so
excited
all right bring it in yeah so we we're
doing some research on these guys who
did the
who did the uh launch the uh
redemption
nfts with carlos and we found some
really wild tweets from the main guy
who was pitching this the head the ceo i
think he labeled himself as yeah by the
way is bitredemption.com still up
oh good question
yeah it's still online
are they still
i gotta find the logo
here it is there it is
can i buy this
this is the one they never launched that
they should have that's the one they
actually own yeah
yeah
so the guy
we dug up some tweets how'd you guys
find this
i don't
i did it how'd you do it i just looked
around
well i i just thought it was a shady guy
i looked at his like nft profile right
and i found a bunch of weird stuff on
there
and then i just [ __ ] looked through
his tweets and uh
i just found some weird [ __ ]
did you have to do like a search
function out of his whole history
because it was an old tweet and i found
it uh no i just scrolled through
all right you guys are gonna love this
apologies my dude i didn't want to do
this uh if they're making me do this
i guess this is probably some kind of
porn star she said if you don't eat
[ __ ] you're a little boy if you don't
care if the girl comes you're a little
boy where the [ __ ] the men minute so
that's what she tweeted
and then maximilian responded okay
i make a girl come like 20 times before
i do once otherwise i won't make her
come as good lol
plus then she wants me so bad ideally
better than any [ __ ] she's ever been
with period crying laughing emoji
oh my goodness i think he's a virgin
i think
what i would guess from this
hmm
maybe he just [ __ ] like nobody before
maybe he does
i mean
you know
go off king like you got to please your
woman i i respect that do not come
i just like i can make a girl come 20
times before i even do it once
yeah for sure for sure awesome kid
[Applause]
awesome
well it's not that bad he's just you
know thirst trapping for some
is there something else love that was
more incriminating than this
no this was the one that was twitter
this was the one that cracked us all up
unless i mean yeah
nothing else
here let's change the title by the way i
know you hate doing this live i'll i'll
write it to you mr beast cancelled
that's pretty good
that's [ __ ] juicy but i'm already
taking my pictures for the dislikes my
dudes
they disabled those so we're fine oh is
it gone
yeah wait i still see it i see it it's
gone for me i see it oh
oh it's sweet
they don't trust those swedes guys
please like the video apparently that
affects search and discovery so please
like and never dislike thank you
no matter how late i am
smash that like button oh here's what
love sees in sweden yeah i still see the
dislike button they made all this hubbub
and it's still there that's interesting
huh must be rolling it out by region or
something
just get rid of the button at that point
i don't know you know
the more i've thought about it the more
i do think that this is
a pretty stupid decision really yeah
well the only possible
point where it can [ __ ] up the content
quality is like tutorials and stuff
other than that i don't understand
that it being a big deal
i feel like
you know
when
big uh
companies
do like a trailer for a movie or a tv
show and it gets like a lot of backlash
and it gets downvoted those are
that's
i think i suspect the main motivation
for removing it those are that is great
honestly it's a shame and i think i
agree that it's great yeah
that is a shame
it's gonna change the world the no
dislike button
the world is not anymore the way it used
to be no no no
this is this is a brave new world we're
living in
so um
now that mr beat's cancelled
we're moving let's take a call let's
check in with the footprints actually do
the ads and then let's take some calls
right after
let's thank our sponsor
quick
we love quip
it's a beautiful
vibrating toothbrush
sorry maximilian was making me come 20
times
i don't know what that means
thank you to quip
quip is a beautiful electric toothbrush
i love it so much it's a slick modern
looking tube
uk doesn't have a charging station or
battery it vibrates when you push the
button and the cool thing is that it
pulsates every 30 seconds to make sure
that you're getting the right amount of
brushing
and the pulsating tells you to move on
to the next quadrant
get that perfect two-minute dentist
recommended brush
you know i love quip it's got soft
bristles they don't [ __ ] up my gums i'll
be honest those are hard for me to find
um
it's lightweight
it's got a reusable handle
they can just send you new bristles
you know
and with the equip new smart motor app
you can track and improve your brushing
with the free quip app and you're also
going to earn rewards like free refills
products target cards and more
it's like if your parents uh loved you
and rewarded you for being good brushing
that's what quip does for you now i
don't know
quip is your mother now yeah quip is
watching always
beyond the brush quip has everything you
need to complete a routine they've got
anti-cavity toothpaste they've got a
special floss that expands to clean
the floss they've got a floss pick that
replaces over 180 disposable picks with
every refill
they got gum
sugar-free long-lasting gum is one of
the best things you can actually do for
your teeth
chewing after every meal makes a big
difference in your oral hygiene
so
if you go to equip get quipped dot com
slash h3tv right now you'll get your
first refill for free
that's your first refill for free at get
quip.com h3 spell g-e-t-q-u-i-p
dot com slash h3 tv quip the good habits
company thank you
quick
next up meundies what the frick
it's time to grow up and get some real
underwear damn it
the days of lugging around
dissolved underwear from middle school
is over okay
get me undies you don't want to impress
a date
have some real underwear on
you know
and not only that me undies is soft it's
breathable it's beautiful it's the
softest most luscious underwear i've
ever
worn
it really is incredible
the holidays are upon us it's time to
really lean in we're talking hugs that
is
this year me undies wants to help you
bring comfort home for the holidays
so yeah i mean
i'm a big fat guy let's be honest i have
a massive waist and those me on these
waistlines just make all the difference
and my thighs are massive
it's just soft it feels so much better
uh with the new classic plaid and
holiday sweater prince my undies is
turning up the comfort this holiday
season their undies loungewear and
sleepwear are made out of soft
breathable stretchy fabrics that are
ideal for getting cozy by the fire and a
cup of hot cocoa make the whole family
smile
with matching pj sets or spoil your
partner with plush robes and slippers
whatever you decide everyone will be
rolling into the new year comfier than
before sizes range from extra small to
4xl meundies has a little something for
everyone on your list looking for more
inspiration check out their holiday gift
guide for all things cozy and
comfortable me andy's has a great offer
for our listeners for any first time
purchase you get 15 percent off and free
shipping right to your door your days of
fighting for your life in the mall
parking lot are over
to get 15 off your first order free
shipping 100 satisfaction guaranteed go
to meundies.com h3tv that's mandys.com
htv h3tv thank you
and finally we have hello fresh
my face is on fire
it doesn't look good
i can't lie
looks very painful pretty exciting for
the show though
that's one way it looks like a beat like
a [ __ ] or a radish
anyway hello fresh
eat hella fresh and you won't look like
me
hello fresh
they deliver fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep
oh
abs burrito
luscious look at this burrito could be
yours what's inside
nobody knows
oh now now we're talking
uh
[Music]
now we're talking
skip the store grocery store and hello
fresh makes home cooking easy fun and
affordable that's why it's america's
number one meal kit let me tell you
about hellofresh they send you a big old
box with dry ice perfectly refrigerated
ingredients proportioned an instructions
kit
arm you with everything you need to make
a beautiful home-cooked meal
for you and your loved ones
it's delicious every time it makes
cooking easy and fun if you're not a
great chef it's a great way to learn if
you are a great chef this is a very
convenient way to just bust out meals
without having to fuss with the grocery
store and buying like 10 pounds of
carrots just use one you know
i love it
as a fall transitions the winter is
nothing better than cozying up with
comfort home cooked meals recipes like
chicken ramen and shoyu style broth and
turkey ragu gnocchi make it a no-brainer
to skip on paying for takeout hello
fresh isn't just for meals their
marketplace features a variety of
add-ons for breakfast dessert and
seasonal snacks like pillsbury pumpkin
cookie dough
yeah the super trooper has been doing it
everyone's been having a great
experience with hellofresh right i'll
get all love
i love it
it's fun i mean i'm gonna have it every
night every night every night yeah saved
our marriage
saved your marriage
well we spent a lot more time together
you know prepping it and eating instead
of just going out
and it's helpful when you're trying to
count your calories as well because
you know fresh provides everything yeah
fantastic
guys
go to hellofresh.com h3tv and use code
h3tv 14. wait i think i said that wrong
guys forget i said that guys go to
hellofresh.com h3tv14
and use code h3tv 14 for up to 14 free
meals
and three free gifts
hellofresh.com
h3tv14 use code h3tv14
thank you to hello fresh america's
number one meal kit
and we're done
hey hey come on now having fun having
good vibes eating hello fresh all the
time don't look like me should put this
music on
the teddy fresh of it
yeah this is good yeah this is good
times
hey
come on
all right let's take a look here
awesome time
uh let's let's look through the calls
there's actually a shitload queued up oh
someone wants to talk to me about my
rash okay here's a nurse practitioner
tammy what's wrong with me hello
i think you had an allergic reaction to
the soap i think you're exactly right
is it odd to you though that like
i've used it before
and i was fine
i mean it could be old you could have
come in contact with something else but
i think what you need to do now is keep
taking the benadryl and then also start
taking pepsin
if you take pepsid over the counter it
actually works against allergies too
pepcid
yeah like for acid reflux but
it also works for allergies i think it
will really help you and then the other
thing i would do is get the dial the
orange dial hand soap
um and wash your face with it don't get
it in your eyes but you don't want those
sites to get infected if you keep
scratching them right yeah so i think if
you add
i think if you add in pepsid and wash
with the orange dial you'll be better in
a few days
that's awesome did you did anyone write
down those medicines
i know i got it yeah thank you so much
and by the way so definitely
i do not i don't need to see a doctor
right let's just make that clear to
everyone who's yelling at me
when did it when did it officially start
i think it started officially on like
friday
okay so if it's not better than friday
then i would if you start taking that
stuff like today or tomorrow but that
actually that's really useful i didn't
know if i should keep taking the
benadryl or not so that's great thank
you so much no i definitely would i
definitely would
tammy you're the greatest that ever did
it how are you
i'm good bring in the benadryl lena
bring in the benadryl
and you really can't overdose on
benadryl yeah oh [ __ ] slam that whole
bottle then
was saying i was going to die of it on
friday no more steroid creams on your
face no more stair creams on your face
please really
okay why i thought that was yeah really
not to put steroids on your face unless
it's a prescript
oh [ __ ] i was i was loading that [ __ ] on
my face
like literally caking my face with it on
the weekend
i was screaming at you on my computer
screen
so why shouldn't i do that
well steroids like your facial skin's a
little bit too sensitive for steroids
and long-term use can cause some damage
unless it's in like a prescribed steroid
from like a doctor
[ __ ] yeah i was i i i was literally iced
out
all right well this is really good
advice thank you so much tammy you save
him you're welcome i hope you feel
better thank you so much appreciate that
eh come on
take care now that's a call isn't it now
that's a call people
when there's a call there's a call
you know
i can't overdose on benadryl is that a
challenge to me
i'm pretty sure you can
the nurse practitioner says i can't well
the person saying they're a nurse
practitioner on the telephone
you're gonna be awesome just pretend
like you know [ __ ] and just lie to me i
mean i don't know she sounded like she
knew what she was talking about
you can get her credentials the girls on
the phone and you overdose on benadryl
you probably have to take like a stupid
amount yeah right what do you what are
you reading there dan
overdose warning
although online challenges may encourage
it whoa is this
written just for us online challenges
let's go it's not safe to take more than
the recommended dosage of benadryl doing
so can lead to overdoses severe symptoms
including abnormal heart rhythms
hallucination seizures and even death in
real yeah but how much are they talking
about
because like the dose is 25 milliliters
what are they talking about whatever i'm
having no idea it's not my it's not my
plans for the week don't worry
okay that was good
matt from
orlando
i've gotten wanted to share his
experience on the judge matthew show
mathis what's the story with judge
mathis i have no idea i don't even know
what that is
do you think it's just like a judge judy
spinoff thing
matt you got a story for us a
money-making hack yes uh
yeah i i scammed the judge mathis show
we got like 3 500 okay wait let me pull
up judge mathis
i'm gonna show a picture but yeah it's a
court show like judge judy oh yeah yeah
what's this guy like is he a real judge
or just some dude
all right
a technical what is the [ __ ] picture
in the middle
did judge matthew rip one out of his
gavel when you were there
dude nah he's he's real straight lace i
think he's like has a history in in law
enforcement somehow yeah this is the
best
trainer
this is my new like avatar in all video
games
so why did you guys target judge mathis
yeah my my roommate at the time he was
he was kind of a screw-up
he ended up going off to rehab and i
paid his rent while he was gone
um and when he came back he had no way
to pay me um
and these shows that the show pays the
judgment
so i was like well i know how you can
pay me back we're to make up a lawsuit
i'm going to fake suyu and then we're
going to go on this show
so they uh they pull us out to chicago
there's the show it's
i know you are talking about reality tv
a couple shows ago but uh
yeah it's it's it's pretty scripted they
don't they don't give you a script but
they the producers come
into your green room and fake news like
why are you lying to us
shows
not bachelor damn
real people real lives
real engagements all right
go ahead go ahead before your room
like i made up this story about how you
know he owed me a lot of money for
breaking a laptop with mine
say you know the producer just ate it up
and they pulled us out i ended up
winning the show
uh winning the uh judgement so the show
paid us uh 250 dollars to appear and
then i got 3 000. that's [ __ ] awesome
dude that is crazy did you guys have did
you like put on a show you know what i
mean did you guys like yell at each
other in the courtroom and everything
yeah so that that's kind of what the
producers like scripted out with us they
were like oh you need to you need to get
real mad at him at some point you know
don't argue the whole time but you you'd
be like oh he just smoked sweet all day
he's the blunt man calling the blunt man
it's not even that funny
by the way is this episode on like
youtube or something can i watch it
no he doesn't stream anywhere i've been
trying to find it um
but yeah he doesn't stream the show
anywhere
they probably don't give a [ __ ] if
you're faking it right i mean they don't
care
yeah i think she had an idea the
producer did because at one point she
was like no if y'all go out to eat
somewhere you know don't submit receipts
for that like i can't i can't reimburse
you for food that you eat together
you're supposed to be fighting
yeah
i i you're probably not the first person
to do this to them far from it actually
yeah
huh that's awesome that's [ __ ] great
yeah you guys that was a great idea you
all had there
good job man yeah but yeah if y'all ever
strap for cash you can get up to 5 000
on those shows
why'd you what damn you should have got
gone for the full five why'd you guys
only get three
so the producer said like before she
flew us out there she called and was
like yeah i can't do the full five
thousand it's going to be hard to get
that approved but i could probably go
for three
cheap asses
that's awesome man you guys are great
that's smart love it
that garyvee garyvee approves yeah
i needed money for teddy fresh that's
what it was my man there you go thank my
regards to judge mathis
[Applause]
thanks bro thank you guys thanks for the
story god bless
that's kind of genius i would never
think to do that
judge
matthew's wendy's
let's go i just saw that somebody in the
chat said that uh judge mathis used to
i'm sorry but judge matt first of all
you know i talk [ __ ] on wendy but who
the [ __ ] are you judge mathis the step
to the queen
die let me watch that video pull it up
oh man it's like 15 minutes long and i
haven't yeah we got [ __ ] time we got
all day
the the die
what's that allergy medicine called
benadryl the benadryl is not even here
yet true
and announced that the reason for her
two-month hiatus was because she was
actually addicted to something yeah see
this is like a
history of the beast
give me a minute
i want to try to find the actual
clip of him calling under that got it
i don't need a recap
i don't want
exactly there's a lot of these videos
apparently it's been a long rivalry
2003.
judge mathis destroys wendy williams
2003. i want the whole breakdown this is
like two decades of beefing i want the
whole breakdown holy [ __ ] while we're
looking here's a short clip of him
imitating a crackhead that maybe we
could throw up while we look
wait is that where the that thumbnail is
from maybe
that's what i was looking for but i
couldn't find it
can you tell me about this guy's
background like who is this guy
so he studied law at the detroit college
of law and then i guess he went to
chicago to shoot a show i'm still
looking at his credentials okay so he he
did go to law school yeah he did go to
law school yeah he went straight from
law school to being a tv judge that
seems like he skipped a few steps he had
to have
practiced it i'm sure he practiced
let me see
actually i heard there's a there there's
a new discipline of law uh tv judge that
you can study now really so you get fast
tracked right to the television no i
made that up
why would you
why would you just lie like that i
thought it was funny i thought it was a
gave what
a gag if you would
[ __ ]
um
you guys want to talk about mr beast
getting cancelled
well since we titled the episode
i guess we should probably i think it's
pretty interesting
there's like very um i would say people
on the far left
are having some better reactions to mr
beast
recreating the entire squid game set and
i gotta say i've been following this
it's [ __ ] insane
what he's done have you guys seen this
[ __ ]
he literally just recreated it like uh
pound for pound
right but my understanding was
it's more than that because the show
itself didn't actually make these sets
it was mostly cg
and then he he actually that's funny
they're like no we didn't build it
that's that'd be insane that'd be such a
waste of money yes correct right
and then mr beast is like say no more
well here
is a little time lapse i think they're
building the red like green light room
yeah
right this one specifically this this
was all green screen in the show
right that's true i remember seeing the
bts right this room was all green
um
he said apparently he spent two million
dollars on this but i have a hard time
believing it wasn't more
excuse me
i think my throat is closing just
kidding sorry
it's just the acid reflux
[Music]
yeah so
this is insane like what the [ __ ] he
actually
that's crazy dude i mean what is
the point of making
the like prison style bunk beds is it
gonna make it i think there'll be a
sleep there i think yeah for sure he's
gonna make people sleep there
hmm okay i'm starting
to maybe lean towards the critics
well we'll see what they say and then
weigh around okay yeah opinions because
that is a little something
i guess i'll disclose at the top here
that i am friends with jimmy i like
jimmy i think he's a great guy
so i'm just going to get that out of the
way sure
um
this this yeah i mean this is like oh my
god they're actually going to kill each
other with knives
right right
i just that wasn't part of the game
it was part of the game well i guess
yeah okay
but
unless people kill each other i just
don't know how this can
be that interesting
um
he recreated this whole place where they
played marbles
yeah i don't know
pretty amazing
i mean obviously just from like the
scale of it it's impressive to pull that
all together and everything
he said i now have every game from squad
game bill in real life i saw him
tweeting some comments about how
where it cost him 2 million or something
or he was saying it cost him more than
he thought it would
trying to find that
i remember him saying that too
um
oh it is in the document thank you
he says it's he spent two million
dollars building the sets and will have
a 1.5 million in prizes damn
that's three and a half million dollar
budget for one [ __ ] youtube video
that's what he does that's like major
studio budget
uh yeah yeah
that's like
i mean how much
game of thrones was the most to ever
cost the show was like 10 million per
but
the first season was less it was like 5
million per which he's approaching oh
yeah no this is on the scale of uh like
a network television show episode that
is bonanza's
quick game budget let's see what the
actual show costs here's all these
people 21 million there you go
and how many episodes was there
uh 10.
so yeah i mean he's it sounds like he's
spending more
yeah he's spending more on this than an
episode of the actual show of game of
thrones no squid game oh
right yeah squid games was super low
budget i thought you were talking about
wait how many episodes were you ready
games you said 10 right i i thought you
were talking about game of thrones
thrones is 15 for the last season the
last season had a way higher budget yeah
that's a difference so squid games had
nine episodes nine episodes okay so 21.4
million divided by nine
yeah it's 2.3 million per episode
roughly so jimmy has found a way to
spend more money per episode
right than actual squid games
although it's not a totally fair
comparison because he built every set
for one video yeah yeah
but still that's pretty incredible
oh someone said he used to live with mr
beast and his insight on the production
process
um okay
mandalorian season one was a 12.5
million per episode yeah i mean
it's probably going to be multiple
episodes on mr beast oh that's true this
video yeah
i hope you get some mileage out of this
okay you're right it'd probably end up
being a few episodes
because he's history he's got to get his
money's worth on this one
okay so let's look at all the the people
who are angry at about the extravagance
spending um let's have a look
and i'm not i'm not blowing this out of
proportion there's a lot of people are
very mad
about this
um
this is just comments how is
how is this
here's one of his tweets with some
replies about it i mean the reply seem
seem mostly supportive here
no
so it sounds like you are blowing it out
of proportion no i oh it does i guess
now but
no there was a lot of people pissed
who was pissed about this like i mean
it's definitely a little i'll tell you
why people are pissed
in the absence of evidence here
is there because squid games is a show
about ultra rich people you know using
poor people as their entertainment their
their guinea pigs and then there's like
a weird there's a weird parallel though
to mr beast super rich making people you
know dance for [ __ ]
huge money right it's like he he's i
guess the criticism is that he's um
he missed the point of the of the he
really missed the mark on that one
david dobrik style uh yeah a little bit
although i mean he's not
he's not killing that mark is he well i
don't know i mean you know he's got to
step it up to the next level
he's always trying to raise the bar
raise the raise the bar a little bit
yeah there was lots of people
complaining about the cost and just
about missing the point i saw some tick
talks about it too
and you know i guess i get it but it's
more of a criticism or society than mr
beast who's just trying to make
entertaining videos
right i was gonna say the same as it's
just like
i don't know
doing extravagant productions costs a
lot of money they spent
spent 20 million dollars on the show
itself
yeah is that extravagant is that yeah is
that is that too much i think it's uh
specifically about making the people
compete for prizes yeah but you know
what jimmy does too and i'll say because
maybe these people don't watch his
videos i do watch his videos he everyone
who appears in his videos gets hooked up
even like the first person out and
everyone in between gets gets paid a lot
of money right i was gonna say it seems
like a little bit of a rush to judgment
if um
you know
it hasn't even come out yet we don't
know what the parameters are and
i mean if it's just one person that's
getting
eyes we got the benadryl and he's going
to kill everybody else then yeah that
would uh i would definitely be missing
the point
all right we got what do we got here
cherry flavored
we got bennies we got chewables daddy
likes
chewables non-drowsy why do you always
need like three types
i i didn't go grocery i just got
everything
it's a farm party oh the kitchen sink
yeah where's my
lina where's my uh mono clue where's my
monoclona toads
my regeneron
sorry i'm just joking if you watch the
show lena you get the reference
oh stop baby
she stop watching unless i join
all right so i'm going to choose some of
these um
here someone this is a popular tweet 8
000 or 9000 likes almost mr beast can
you do something else maybe make homes
for almost people that might be a good
idea you know
again to be fair to jimmy he does do a
lot he because i think he knows the
optics and he's always doing his best to
actually do good things too like he's
always giving doing these insane food
drives cleaning up the sea planting
trees you know just because he's not
doing what your
narrow definition of helping
is uh he he does a lot of charity i
don't know what to say yeah and he's
just he's a youtuber like
i i
again i i can sort of see the criticism
but it really doesn't need anything more
than a mild like
eye roll
like it's nothing to be that upset about
it's it's a [ __ ] youtube video i see
the irony i see that yeah exactly it's
just like right it's not i wouldn't like
sir i can't get these kid saved my ass i
can't get it open maybe it's working
even with your manly ass hands you can't
no it's like i ripped it too hard and oh
you're too manly bro
i think this is for kids so i gotta take
like well it's so little
so this is 12.5 it's for kids
somebody asked if this is an ad for
benadryl now yes actually it is
you can pick benadryl up at your local
pharmacy cvs or walgreens i'd say so bad
use code it's http it's just alone it's
like adam sandler movie
[Laughter]
get some duncancinos up in here my dude
yeah what's my name duncancino
it's a whole new game
anyway can you guys find more people
[ __ ] talking beast because i i find it
interesting
i think it would be super funny if mr
beast just got homeless people to do
this and give the winner
a hundred thousand billion dollars and
give everyone else ten dollars for
participating
people just be mad
people just be mad for no reason
there is irony
mr beast almost like a giant food bank
too i think yeah exactly he has a whole
channel where he donates all the money
to
food banking
i'm scrolling through the quote tweets
and i got to be honest it's just a lot
of people saying like people are stupid
for being mad about this
no i hate this there's like there's the
anti it's the anti-circle jerk is uh is
dominating the quote tweets right now
like look on tick tock i saw some really
um
well we kind of missed the mark with
this one kind of missed the mark with
that one no i'm telling it's out there
and it's really interesting i sent some
um
deaf noodles and collected some too yeah
go ahead dan while i chug this benadryl
okay is this instagram link
oh yeah this is what deaf noodles has to
say about it hot take but i feel like
once you've reached this level of wealth
maybe you should be using said wealth to
benefit the impoverished and not
read the whole thing come on we're we're
interacting even through the eye roll
impoverished and not uses to recreate a
show that is a direct critique of the
exact thing being done here but hey
that's just me well your name is exactly
you know we're not gonna
oh
so no such thing as a coincidence die
daughter why don't you do something
about isis
[Music]
next let's google some isis videos
americans are genuinely too stupid
for even korean movies and film with the
most obvious allegories of all time it's
not a film or a movie it's a television
show made by an american again yeah i i
acknowledge the the the irony but
it's still gonna i'm still gonna watch
that [ __ ] way to miss the point of the
entire show holy [ __ ] yeah see that's i
mean that's that's
i don't have a problem with this
sentiment you know what i mean
ironic
does director uh i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna try i'm gonna embarrass myself
trying to say his name
uh no can't stop it say it
huang dong hyuk that's fine
uh know about this already i hope they
sue him that is that's actually that is
interesting i wonder if there is uh
litigation i don't know
he
i mean he certainly has the the money
and clout to get clearance but i don't
know if he did
i feel like they wouldn't give it to him
because of the
big promotion for the show though that's
true netflix well netflix probably has
the rights right exactly i wonder if
it's well i can see jimmy um yeah
he's at the level that he could easily
you know i guess we'll find out i i
think this might be a collaboration deal
oh yeah that could explain the budget
because netflix has a really vested
interest in keeping this show going sure
this is nothing but promo for it so well
if netflix is actually co-signing this
then i think that's just a huge w right
right
they would have to otherwise yeah he
would get sued into the ground i mean
they're he's using the name
like all of the images using the name
the imagery yeah that's pretty but
that's pretty
if it's not sponsored by netflix
that's a pretty interesting might be a
lot more than 2.5 million or 3.5 million
whatever it was
rich people have lost the plot so
[ __ ] bad you know these are just like
[ __ ] he says 200. also like jimmy's
rich but let's be honest again there's
like rich
like
and then there's like jimmy's probably
starting to drink trend into rich rich
you think so i mean he's he always tells
everybody he's successful he always
tells me that he spends almost
everything he makes but i guess i could
maybe see that being true i don't know
when i was like the mr beast burger and
stuff like he's not you don't think he's
well you know i i got pitched to do one
of those and the profit margins were so
[ __ ]
it was the same um same people same
people that he partnered with but he's
doing crazy volume well i'll tell you
the story about jimmy we met in vegas
just by random circumstance i saw him
was so weird me and either were there
for a weekend yeah and he just walked by
when we were shopping i called his phone
i was like are you in vegas and he's
like yeah we played poker together this
[ __ ]
his assistant had a backpack full of
literal cash and every time he lost
which was often because
he's got a fetish for losing money
his assistant came in and put stacks
down and just brought him more chips
it's pretty amazing i never seen
anything like that that's crazy
apparently they did a video where there
was like a bunch of
loose fives and singles and they had a
bunch of bills left over so they just
put it in a backpack and got went to
vegas
with like a hundred thousand dollars in
[ __ ] loose bills
it's a little
a little extravagant
his net worth is 15 to 25 million
probably yeah
yeah okay
that's not that's not quite rich rich i
do that's rich i think he spends a lot
of money and then very rich good thing
he does is when he gives prizes he pays
their taxes for them
which is kind of crazy
for the people that he gives the money
to like if you if someone wins a ferrari
a 300 000 car
usually what happens you give them the
car and then the government says thanks
you owe us you know a hundred thousand
dollars in tax because they count it as
cash
right so most people have to sell the
car
uh to pay the tax right well jimmy at
least last time we spoke to him when he
was on the podcast he said he pays
people's tax so they actually get to
keep the [ __ ]
which means he's paying probably thirty
percent more right than even whatever i
wonder if he's paying registration on it
too because i those will be astronomical
as well that's true yeah registration is
really expensive on that assurance
he's not known he's probably on they're
probably on your own like if you're a
pleb if you're a dude who's making like
let's be honest under 100 000 a year you
can't [ __ ] afford to have a ferrari
you got to sell that [ __ ]
because the insurance on that is super
expensive
the gas is insane
you know
i would just sell that
i'm not finding anything
official
about
this thing being a collab with netflix
how could it not be though i've been
looking to you i don't see anything well
like literally how could it not be he's
been pretty mums the word about it so
far
maybe he'll reveal that when the video
comes out or whatever yeah
i'll be a little worried for him if it's
not yeah i mean it's just
but the guys i understand the irony but
you got to take the whole thing as a
whole jimmy
does a lot of [ __ ] charity he does a
ton of good [ __ ]
because he knows the optics right he's
aware of what it looks like so he's
always consciously doing good [ __ ]
to make sure that he can continue doing
what he's doing morally
yo
ferrari insurance is eight thousand
dollars for six months
wait what yeah that makes sense i'm
telling you that you can't you have to
be rich to drive you have to literally
not care about money to drive that car
some went up to 12 000 for six months
because those cars are first of all
super dangerous people crashing them
it's worth a lot of money
it's basically everything wrong that you
want as an insurance seller right
yeah
wow
yeah so like
if you see anyone who's
you know you have to be a millionaire
you even if you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year
you're looking at sixteen thousand
dollars a year and just insurance alone
right oh [ __ ] that
i i mean that's that's astronomical
five percent
[ __ ] a
i guess uh did we find any other
interesting uh beast
are we moving on
uh there's more in this album but i mean
these tweets have like 16 likes no some
of them had a lot well
i don't know where they are
and neither does death noodles
apparently
he's got 12 likes he's got 12 like
tweets in his post
i went to three articles and they're
showing these screenshots and one of the
articles mentioned deaf
it's just a snake eating its own tale of
people being mad on the internet
right that's interesting
okay well shout out shout outs to beast
so you don't think you don't think he'll
be successfully canceled
i don't think it's not a real should you
ask him to change the title
no no
no i would never i would never
i would never question the clickbait no
it's not i don't think even people are
trying to cancel them i think it's just
the irony the irony is right
and i see it yeah and i and i respect
the people getting mad online about it
but also
touch grass
simultaneously
um tim pull the quartering this is good
oh i had a i had a twitter beef with tim
pool and well not less tim pool because
he didn't even respond to me but
i know he was angry because i ratioed
him
okay first of all tim poole and the
quartering you guys probably know
they're just they're your
run-of-the-mill
conservative online shills uh tim poole
is tim's civil war pool
is
thirsting he is frothing at the mouth
for a new civil war because you need to
get vaccinated that's basically the
tipping point for him bag of turret you
know flaming turd bag
he
he said and i quote guys
if sex work is work then can a boss
require women to suck his dick as a job
requirement this is a why did he tweet
this this is a
i wish that the likes were here
it's still up yeah pull it up because it
actually
and i remind this is a prominent right
wing thinker this is tim
he's a liberal actually that's what he
always says i'm a classical liberal i'm
a dis disinfected
disinfectant
disaffected liberal is what it says in
his uh
in his bio
i'm sorry i'm gonna get pissed off about
that yeah so um this
at first when i read this i had to
double check it to make sure it wasn't a
parody account
i checked it like three times because i
just couldn't believe it if sex work is
work then can a boss require women to
suck his dick as a job requirement
interesting
yeah it's still there 20 000 likes
i like that response underneath the
masculine urge to do anything but go to
therapy
that's awesome well anyway you got uh
temple went on this epic uh rant about
how he's single and he doesn't have a
family at you know the age of 30 and
it's not his fault it's everyone else's
fault and i so i said this is why you're
single
and i [ __ ] uh ratioed him hard
thank you round of applause
please clap
good job good ratio my brother
um why did he tweet this
i don't know what like what
what i know why why it's like
but also you can't think that that's
actually like a logical conclusion
i mean it
if sex work is work then can a boss
require
women to suck
as a job requirement
genuinely asking
well that's like saying that's like
saying if a b is a carpenter
can i require him to
you know
fix my roof
i fixed your roof yeah you would bad
analogy
and now i'm gonna get pissed off without
a terrible analogy that's exactly what
you would expect the carpenter to do
no but if he's working here
he's here he's a b to fix your your your
personal he's got to fix my [ __ ] well
you shouldn't pick a b because he's such
a simple he would i'm using a hyper
that's me if
dan was a carpenter
and you came to be our producer
and but i was like but also as part of
your job description is you have to
[ __ ] fix my house oh i can't jerk off
to this
what
what the [ __ ] was that
entourage of sounds was just files zack
played that fart time again
that wasn't me that was me i mean that
was me laughing wait what
i yeah do that sound again
i could attempt yeah
oh okay
shoot sound bite that zack
there's a longer one for you surprise me
wow
oh
god
so he's saying if sex work is real work
then
as part of boss can require as part of
our official duties fellatio
asking for a friend
i'm asking
well i have this girl who i just hired
and
you might want to you might yeah you
might want to keep that offline tim
whatever fantasy you're having there bro
he has a such a powerful brain he really
does i understand
i understand
why he has the audience that he does
with uh
such insights as this it's incredible
hassan said no it's feminism i said
feminism is no when no [ __ ]
the quartering came to defend his daddy
tim
and i didn't quite understand his
response uh
maybe people were guessing maybe he he
ate the bait he ate the onion as they
say with all the click bait about me and
ela breaking up i think even that's
giving him too much credit i think he's
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] and just
i don't know [ __ ] all over the floor
just thinks you're you're an unhappy
you're unhappy in your marriage that's
just funny because
like
i don't know well okay he says thanks
you know thanks for the dating advice i
first of all it wasn't for you bro
it was a statement of fact anyway you
look super happy in your marriage i
don't know it's like based on what are
you making that
you guys seem happy
yeah we are happy you know we were six
we have a good life together we got a
child coming on yeah
on the way in a couple months
but like that would make sense if there
was like
if you're like the ace family and yeah
there's rumors of infidelity and stuff
that that would be like ooh what a jab
right but
he's just kind of pulling it out of thin
air yeah it's like the rice gum argument
of oh no wonder why you're so unhappy
look at you and your girl like i'm deep
undercover
with no basis well it's ironic for him
to say he's the one that got pizza
cocked and then had the [ __ ] in his own
[ __ ] open drain
this is true uh he only peed in the
drain yeah
[Music]
he's [ __ ] at walmart
the quartering
he waffle stomps [ __ ] down his basement
drain
anyway i said at least my pizza has at
least my pizza
at least my wife has never gone for
pizza without me
you know
not only have i never been pizza cooked
but i also have never peed in an open
drain in my basement in a drunken
cockrage
oh he responded i didn't see it oh dude
oh that's so disappointing because
reading this just reminded me of the
fact that like less than a month ago he
was like
thirsty posting like super horny posting
about gina carano on twitter yeah we
talked about it right he deleted all of
those tweets oh i just went i wonder how
his wife felt about all that
oh my god a little came out he goes you
showed your feet
right he goes you showed your feet what
fan service
and then he was like doctoring up
pictures of them together right yeah no
wonder his wife goes out of pizza
without him who could [ __ ] stand your
ass vile f
you're vile man
you are truly vile anyway here he
responded this is my first time reading
this imagine being ethan klein
okay just imagine all right hold on
just imagine it my face hitches man
alive the man
is man alive i have to [ __ ]
my dick yeah exactly you're right now
you're taking a paw you're right in the
zone [ __ ] all over the floor
[Laughter]
man alive this dude just sweats
bitterness you're like
you [ __ ] came out
how are you gonna accuse me of
bitterness you're the one that tweeted
at me
that i'm unhappy in my marriage and his
whole
his whole brand is bitterness all he
does is post about how pissed off he is
because [ __ ] marvel you know
he's got too woken or whatever
such an incel bro exactly you sell
bitterness you bottle it and sell it to
incels that's your brand
i wasn't thinking about you at all i'm
not bitter
what was the term you used to describe
him dan he's a um
oath uh never been a clear definition of
an i think he's more of an ogre german
um i feel like oath is not vile enough
for him
he's got to be like an ogre or a troll
like a real trouble and stupid
ogre well let's read the definition of
an oath
of definition oh my god it's just a
picture of him what whoa
stupid uncultured or clumsy person yeah
that's pretty good it's all dumb
let's let's read ogre
i'm getting a little loopy from the
benadryl yeah i bet
ogre definition so
a little slow here
because i wonder if ogre can be used
a hit so a hideous giant
right that's
good well he's not
okay wait he's
they represent a mean ugly human-like
monster
i bet you didn't know that
anyway let me continue reading he says
i really hope you can find happiness one
day it's really rough to watch as he was
one of a lot of creators i looked up to
a long time ago oh my god you're so
[ __ ] sad bro
what do you want me to do send you a
little consolation though
you were so sad
man alive
[Music]
yeah he found out i was jewish and then
he's like i can't be friends with this
guy i'm out
actually no what happened was uh that
basically
i uh started being more open about my
politics and uh then they realized they
don't like me
cancel culture run amok once again
thanks jeremy but the truth is if i can
shed viewers like the quartering and
anyone like him
that's that's good you know that's a
good thing for me
i am of course
a white supremacist
it's it i've talked about this a lot of
times but there was a point in my
youtube career when i was doing all this
anti-social justice warrior stuff and my
channel was exploding it was like the
best time for my channel
in terms of subs and stuff and everyone
was loving it
but i noticed you know a lot of dudes
like the quartering who are you know
total reactionary conservatives
bordering on you know
anti-feminism
anti-uh
immigrations
bordering on white supremacy um i was
like i [ __ ] can't fall into this trap
of and turn into like the reuben report
where i [ __ ] have to like pretend
like i'm a conservative to make money
you know what i mean
and so i just said [ __ ] it i'm gonna i'm
gonna get rid of all these people
and uh
it's been a painful process for sure but
a good one
that's led me to being more true being
true to myself in my belief so when i
see him say something like it's really
rough to watch as he was someone a lot
of creators looked up to a long time ago
that that actually is good
because it means that people like him no
longer look up to me and i think that's
fantastic
thank you
now he he is actually just a
horrible horrible dude a really vile
tin pool as well
although tim pool is a little more put
together i don't think he's taking a
[ __ ] in his basement it's waffle stumped
it
but he still has no girlfriend the
quartering's married so go figure that
out
i'd rather be single than get pizza [ __ ]
though
plus he's got that crotch rod so i mean
yeah
my wife went out with pizza without me
my wife went out for yogurt stop me and
then i had a hard time the rest of the
weekend yo that's a really good point
you know it's ironic that she pizza
cucked him and went out because pizza is
one of the only foods you don't even
need to go out for
you can you can eat it at home and have
a great experience but she went made the
extra effort to go out for the pizza
to leave his ass at home and that's what
called being pizza cocktails
it's a great point yeah
that's [ __ ] interesting dude i'm
[ __ ] myself
oh man he's he's awesome he these are
the best man like his sound by surges
yeah this is awesome i love these guys i
mean they're entertaining
tim tim is smart he doesn't respond to
me you know
even though he got ratioed
he keeps his head low well he thinks
you're ruining everything
yeah his soundbite yeah he says
you've been climbing ethan klein is is
damaging everything making it all worse
that was because we dared to talk to sam
cedar
and ruin the delicate beautiful
discourse
i'm going to call you
a bad person oh breaking my heart tim
he actually said that about me because
we goofed on crowder
these guys are so fragile it's crazy
yeah good stuff
fun times
i can hear someone chewing into the mic
by the way i think that's love
yeah that's me my bad what you eating
some shapes
gretel fill and look
or something like that how about that
huh
yeah it's really good actually
can we get a shot of love eating his
chips here pick it up go ahead
into the mic
damn
okay
damn very good
yeah if love bots on his last wheel here
so
if his screen turns off we've got a plan
b
we're gonna put
chad love up
[Music]
oh you guys want to try the mischief
chips
yeah let's do that
um we've got the mischief chips
it's right over here i think
also i want to talk about the gta
definitive edition
it's awesome
i have to admit
even though
it looks like they botched it
pretty badly
seeing that it it does make me want to
go back and play those games
i mean even with all the glitchiness and
shitty graphics and stuff so what is
this we got here another mischief
classic these are the guys who did the
um
this isn't sponsored by the way i just
think it makes good content so i like
when they send me stuff they're the ones
that sent me the um
the david dobrik and trisha warning
warning we're about to enter the chew
zone warning warning all right i'm not
going to go crazy get like a clacks on
so that my clacks on they made
illegal chips
banned in the u.s
oh [ __ ] i can't eat these yeah i know
i'm i'm a vigilante like ayden ross
[Music]
you can only eat these chips in mexico
mexico and some provinces of canada
um food banned in the u.s it's illegal
chips these guys always come up with
something
new
illegalchips.com
so here we have
here you guys you guys should test it
out too
this is horse meat flavored
i might pass on that one
this one is um
cashew
marzu maggot cheese
disgusting
this one is uh i guess i only have two
of that one
uh fugu poison blowfish flavored
is this the one from the simpsons where
he ate the blood fish and they thought
he was gonna die
that's right that's a great episode
dan's vegan could he have the horsemeat
ones well i doubt it actually has horse
meat let's be honest i was kind of
wondering it says on the back made from
zero percent real fugu poison blowfish
made from zero percent real horse
made from zero percent uh
real cashew marzu maggots so yes you can
eat them
it just looks like lay's
does it taste gross it's not bad it's
just
i think it's the the mental expectation
makes it gross yeah it's
even knowing that
yeah
i'd rather try the blowfish than the
horse one
i'm gonna try the horse one now you're
right like i know that it's not horse
meat but this is like grossing me out
thinking about eating this yeah
like it tastes fine i think it's just
no no no no the worst one
or something off about that
i don't like that
this is the maggots
i think they're just normal chips but it
just grosses you out the thought of it
yeah
yeah really
i don't know if it's just getting in my
head but
i think it's just normally chips
like seriously just getting in my head
the the blowfish one they taste pretty
good actually
the blowfish one that's the one i just
tried
i didn't like any of them
well i guess it's a funny little gag to
do with your
friends and fam
you know i gotta wash this down this is
like grossing me out yeah it's
disgusting i hated it
i actually do think it's just lace chips
though
i don't know
something weird going on there
someone said my respect has gone down
you know it's not real animals right
bro
uh no animals were harmed in the making
of these chips
thank you
[Applause]
okay let's move it on
and if any interesting calls let's go
back to the calls somebody says please
ask ian about red taylor's version and
all too well
yeah is that english was that word salad
what was that
did that make sense to you
i mean i i know what they're talking
about yeah it might be a little in the
weeds
go ahead
oh oh is it the t it's the taylor swift
that's the thing you were talking about
oh
got it just the way i guess that's the
name of the album or something the way
that was worded i was like what am i
seeing right here
yeah just taylor swift fans are mad at
jake gyllenhaal
they got beef
they got mad beef went in and uh went in
on a new song talking about him
saying he dates girls too young
oh you're talking about the jake
gyllenhaal thing yeah what was that i'm
not i just saw everyone was [ __ ] on
him all of a sudden
and i guess taylor what i understand a
song about them they dated like 10 years
ago yeah she was he was 30 she was 20.
something like that yeah and they dated
for a very short period of time and he
dumped her
and she
made
a whole album about it or just a song
about it song or maybe songs songs how's
she still singing about this dude though
because there was a re-release of the
album
is it the whole thing where she's
re-recording all of her albums to get a
get out getting under her contract yeah
so this guy he [ __ ]
she she
was like [ __ ] this dude 10 years ago
and now she's saying
re-releasing the album he's got to deal
with all this right but apparently the
song about him
it's like an extended like 10 minute
version of it
by taylor swift about how much she hates
uh jake gyllenhaal 30 year old dating a
20 year old i mean pretty gross i guess
well now he's like
the taylor swift fans were finding out
like his girlfriend he met when she was
like 21 or 22 and he was like 37 this
time
well it's the leonardo actually leo
doesn't even date that young he said
he's right at the sweet age of 24. let's
get glam
he does that's the that's the upper end
that's the cut off he dates them until
they hit i don't understand these guys
you look so stupid dating a [ __ ] 20
year old when you're 36
just [ __ ] find someone older i mean
what could you swift dated okay so he
was 29 not quite 30 but yeah 29 she was
20.
here let me see look up his current
girlfriend
don't you agree they just look like kind
of pathetic when it's like you really
wanna is that i not only do i agree but
i and i say this
with peace and love to the younger
members of our audience i don't mean
this as an insult but i i
cannot imagine
spending time with the 20 year old look
it's not that there's a 34 year old man
there's it's not this my heart stopped i
thought you were going to say something
that you can't listen to taylor swift i
was like don't do it
oh i would never go against the switch
yeah i would never go again
i know better
it's not that there's plenty of 20 year
olds that are cool that i like and are
awesome like mature cool great sure but
it's just different points in your life
yeah exactly that's right
you're probably looking to make a family
you're
buying you're you know there's just more
serious life things than it's if you
remember where you were when you were 20
years old you're basically just going
out taking drugs [ __ ] around not
caring about anything yes because you're
only 20 and the consequences of of
living life have aren't even gonna hit
you for another like five to ten years
but jake gyllenhaal's 36 this
[ __ ] needs to have different
priorities than what a 20 year old is
prioritizing
that's exactly right
thank you
wait do you say he's 36
he's 37 i don't know he started he's 40
he's 40. yeah i was gonna say i didn't
think he was that close in age to us
i mean it's still pretty close he met
his girlfriend when he was thirty-seven
right and she was 22.
37 and 22. that's a juicy age gap
now apparently
taylor swift fans are
going after
uh all of her exes so now they're coming
for a john mayer
dude being an ex of taylor swift is one
of the most cursed things you can do
evidently wait what did john mayer i i
know people hate john mayer too and i
don't know why
i think he just kind of has a reputation
of being
i'm not saying he is i just i that's
that's been floating around him for a
long time
i don't i don't really know why i don't
know what the history of that is he
comes to college pretty funny in this
thing that he understands well love
you're 21. you just turned 21 um are you
insulted by anything we're saying
no i just think it's funny
i i i realized i came across that like
i'm saying [ __ ] young people i'm not i
was speaking specifically you were
saying [ __ ] young people i was saying
young people are
rule just to be clear
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
anyway um
is john mara douche i'm gonna type that
is john mayer a douche people in the
chat saying john was 32
and dated taylor swift when she was 19.
wow
oh here's an article you guys will be
happy to know john mayer claims he's no
longer a douche
i'm a recovering ego addict john mayer
has confessed that he used to be so
self-obsessed that his need for constant
attention approval started to control
his life the
year old candidly referred to himself as
a recovering ego addict oh wow he sounds
like an absolute [ __ ] psycho to say
that about himself
yeah that's a bad date that guy
especially as an 18 year old that guy
will [ __ ] you up
what
the child was saying 19 that she was 19.
here's an article called
john mayer may be the biggest douche of
all time
go ahead like i said i don't know i i
mean i don't know why he has this
reputation but i've just always
seen that popping around the internet
that
he's known as a douche
someone said
uh a douche is i'm assuming in reference
to him
painfully self-aware man
with delusions of coolness
who loves loves loves talking about his
myriad sexual conquest
particularly if they're a-list conquests
like jennifer aniston jessica simpson
excuse me what about taylor
he's uncharitable taylor erasure but
generally harmless
okay whatever what do you want from me
not trying to [ __ ] him
stop [ __ ] him ladies
we need to we need a uh
we need a [ __ ] embargo on john mayer
can can i
i don't want to defend him
but
who knows
i'm a pretty big john mayer fan you can
like his music yeah yeah yeah
he he he definitely has douchebag
tendencies i'm not denying that but
the man can play the guitar like
okay like a [ __ ] man so do you
think i should lift the [ __ ] embargo
maybe yeah okay all right we'll lift it
we'll lift it for zach
um
yeah it's interesting well shout out to
the swifties
can i say i like taylor swift
every interview i've seen with her i
think she comes off really well she
seems very smart and uh charismatic
is that is that um
i don't know anything about taylor swift
yeah she literally don't know anything
she seems bright i like her as a person
are you swifty at all ian
i used to listen to her a decent amount
not as much these days is she is what's
her what's her deal she's like
i mean people like her right i mean i
know she's like her fans like her one of
the biggest artists in the world i know
her fans like her but like outside of
her fandom i wonder what's her
reputation
i mean apparently this re-release which
is an album that came out 10 years ago
is
the highest streamed
album by a female artist ever
in the first day and it's a re-release
yeah wow
good for you
and john mayer's crying right now or i
mean
jake gyllenhaal's crying right now maybe
both
dude if i was like a perfect 10 like
big [ __ ] perfect shea
millionaire and perfect age range for
taylor swift and she we started flirting
and getting on i'd be scared
because you know all of her exes get
blasted the [ __ ]
i would i don't know if you'd have to
think twice before you engage that
relationship
i feel like she's like trisha paid us to
the music world
she just she just [ __ ] canceled me
she blasts everyone [ __ ] up
big time
holy [ __ ] dude i stand by your statement
they're coming for you you know what i
do zach
i disavow everything being said right
now are you worried that i mentioned
trish or that i said taylor's you
compared her to trisha i wasn't
listening again
yeah right i heard you coughing you were
giving me a sign
everyone's like no
everyone's like no you're not making a
joke
i love taylor we stan a queen all the
time
trolling we do a little trolling we do a
little trolling
we like to troll
yeah you may have weathered the bts guys
i love taylor stop stop it put the
swifty i'm reading the chat it's just a
joke it's just a joke
she just we like to troll she doesn't
expose in her songs that's all i'm
saying
i'm sure she's wonderful misogyny
people are shouting everyone's losing
their mind in chat
we stand we stand we stand queen swifty
we do great music like all seriously i'm
a fan did we ever resolve who [ __ ] who
was right or wrong in that kanye kim
first taylor
what are you referring i'm asking ian
specifically
what happened remember uh they
kim and kanye had some crazy conspiracy
to make taylor look like [ __ ]
and they everyone was calling her a
snake and like turned on her for a while
because they were oh
he mentioned her in a song and
oh right she was nude in one of the
videos right
i mean he's got that song famous about
her so did we ever figure out who
bamboozled who in that situation
because they taylor like denied it and
they recorded her just to be clear as a
mannequin of her not actually yeah yes
ian uh
what do you think about the situation
about kanye
it looks like he doesn't want to answer
just silence i frankly i don't remem
remember if there was
additional information on that they
posted the thing where he asked her a
question i don't know i don't know
people are saying they lot kim and kanye
lied
taylor isn't right i'm seeing let's do a
poll just because i don't know i don't
think anyone remembers but let's see
let's say
who was right taylor
or
kanye plus kim
my vote is
i vote all day yeah
all day all day baby
all day i'm voting for tay my girl um
all right
i and by the way i'm voting with no
recollection oh 80 date day get [ __ ]
kim
[Applause]
no way that's so [ __ ] up
yeah because there was like a whole big
drama but oh god no i'm afraid i just
licked the benadryl
cap
dude
that's very not good well it's empty he
just licked the bottom of it because it
fell on the floor i know
he had a very small amount but let's see
if that's fine
i mean it just fell and then he fell
right in front of him and he took a look
benadryl is a relatively safe and
effective medication for dogs okay
oddly enough the only thing i'm scared
about is [ __ ] grapes
grapes kids yeah grapes are like weirdly
crazy poisonous whenever someone brings
grapes in the house i like freak out
like my brother moved here recently he
was staying with us and they bought like
raisins and i was like no [ __ ]
raisins i tell you know everybody no
[ __ ] raisins in the house i just get
so paranoid about it so little also i
found out onions are toxic to dogs too i
think onions just give them diarrhea
like they shouldn't eat it
but grapes can actually kill them
so much like chocolate
chocolate actually is way less dangerous
than than perceived really chocolates
more like onions we'll just give them
diarrhea but grapes are just grapes and
there's this one artificial sweetener
that are well like straight up
poison the dogs that's crazy
like one grape can kill a dog that's
insane i never if they're really if like
a small dog yeah my dogs if they want
grape there's a chance they die oh my
god it's crazy like straight organ
failure it's so scary they don't know
why it does it either
wow
yeah
it sucks because theodore loves grapes
also we are no longer
we are no longer grape games yeah we
hate grapes
well i hate crepes they give me
i have night terrors about great i may
have encouraged
the fan base to start spamming grapes
instead of tomatoes earlier today oh no
i did not realize why would you want to
kill my dogs dan i thought you liked my
dogs i do i do i didn't i didn't make
the connection
i apologize it was very insensitive of
me
um
by the way thank you to all of our
members please consider becoming a
member
you get
[ __ ] politically soon
one day early and also you get to be one
bts every week compliments of a b
what then i didn't realize we were still
doing the pitch there um
very soon here um we will
have access to
uh gift memberships sort of like if
you're familiar on twitch
you can purchase gift subs and give them
out
uh to other fans as just kind of like a
nice little gesture they are introducing
it on youtube and we uh recently got
approved to um
add the feature to our channel so
no and a lot of the other features that
they said uh they're giving us are but i
don't what are the other features that
that we have well we actually have the
ability to do like the equivalent of a
raid no oh there's a setting in our
stream to select another channel or
another stream um
can you send them to a vaude
i think it's just streams and premieres
but let me send them to my own vod
it's like
but yeah we can uh send our uh fans over
to another stream or something so it's
basically gifting subs and rating is is
what it is um also like the mods now
have the ability to create polls there's
like a there's like a few other little
nice features yeah clips similar to
they're in the process of rolling it all
out yes so um but yeah they're basically
just ripping everything off from twitch
and moving it over to youtube so they
had this big uh offering for
streamers trying to quote them over from
twitch
and i was like well what the [ __ ] we
were streaming i wrote them my email i
said what the hell frick and then they
gave us all the features
pretty cool
what they need
to can you imagine if youtube did the
youtube prime or whatever or they give
you a free sub then it'd be over
um
true that's really coming because they
are
moving towards doing that now obviously
like
more people have amazon prime than this
but
they did so they should do a youtube
premium sub
well what they're doing is that it's a
tie-in with discord so
if you get youtube premium you have
discord premium and vice versa they're
like integrated now so if you get like
uh that would be a game changer if
youtube did free subs that'd be that's
huge that'd be huge they i bet they will
because that's such a
winning formula for twitch i mean when
we were streaming 75 of our subs were
free yep
and now it's 100 paid and so obviously
if
right people had free ones that would be
a literal game-changer for us
well that's cool anyway gta definitive
this was space what what number was this
they remade the classic gta
it was three of them oh so they made all
three of them into one
you remastered their graphics
here it is folks feast your eyes
there's a 20-21 character to come back
this is the first time for me in the
gta universe yo this guy's arms
are so cool that's gangster bro
[Laughter]
some spaghetti arms
yeah look at this [ __ ] this is high
level 2021 graphic space this one on the
right has become a meme very quickly
here i mean nobody's face looks like
that
what were they thinking
why even bother if this is the graphics
what the [ __ ] am i looking at dude
my god
these are like the graph i don't even
think graphics were ever this bad
you know if you go back to like the
early 2000's like n64
but they're even they're great for more
polish than this
this is doo-doo fingers in that one
oh this is legit
what is this a pear man
wait go back up a couple i think you
missed yeah look at this guy's hand this
one oh i thought he had a claw that's
his fingers
i thought he was doing like a wolverine
weapon what the hell
freddy krueger dlc
so are people pissed oh yeah this is hot
check this out
look at that that's the body of a gotti
right there my dudes
what in god's green english earth is
that
[Music]
it's america baby so there you have it
lots of good memes coming out of that
oh i have some reviews even
review from a fan
first of all [ __ ] rock star
the definitive edition trilogy is
absolute garbage 60 bucks for a heap of
[ __ ]
the audio files are trash because the
studio was too [ __ ] numb to properly
upscale or even move them
i think he meant dumb
the game can't even run consistent 60
frames on performance mode on a ps5
that's pretty sad
considering it came out 20 years ago or
whatever it was
the game came out 20 years ago i expect
people to play that [ __ ] on a calculator
there are multiple places where terrain
is missing the land bridges and the
boonies and a few spots too the vehicles
and pedestrians exactly like cyberpunk
disappear or replace with
looking away and back at them also
several characters have as you know
horrible issues with their models and
lastly several areas in each game have
noticeable seams
plus part of the holes in vice and
several areas in san andreas and you may
be thinking well to fix it but they
probably won't because the studio that
remade it is the same one that did the
mobile ports so forget any long-term
support [ __ ] you rockstar okay
love the passion
love the passion my friends
my eyes are itchy
it's spreading
people are saying these models look like
a sun
the tiny head
you guys want to get some food what's up
with that
what's up with that
that's up to you
let's get food
dean lena
are doing a private chat let me message
this man needs food
here while you deal with that why don't
i uh read some super chats
what do you think about that
yeah go for it of course
um let's order food
it's just a few carrots it's not
actually
but
go ahead dan yep
the super chat
no
if you want mexican i can get tacos or
maybe veggie grill and i can get the far
east ball
somebody donated five dollars and said
it's the definitive educ
wow you can unmute me uh someone give me
a membership i'm broke yeah i don't
think we can do that yet unfortunately
um
[Music]
h3 podcast action movie skit called
ethan klein man alive
and quartering inspired
uh did you guys already talk about the
new video of oj trying to kiss a girl
and getting swerved i have it in my
doctor yes we have another job
uh i have premium i should be free
member
i agree
i actually agree with you yeah you
should be a free member for your premium
that needs to be the move
definitely
here's the juice uh dude who killed his
wife and her
friend allegedly
well please
well he was found guilty in a civil
court so it's not alleged he also wrote
a book that was never published called
if i did it so
this is yours truly
[ __ ] you oj anyway he's about to get
[Applause]
she runs into him at a club
he's like okay this is happening goes in
for the kiss
and she's like
hell no look at her face
she's protecting her neck
so [ __ ] close up to her like well
look how she protect her neck she knows
what he's capable of [ __ ] weird i
probably reminded him of someone
wait what is that man oh my god
oh he's with his ex-wife ex-wife she
does have a resemblance yeah look at
here i got the perfect look at that
oh she's like oh boy he's like
it's me oj that frame
holy [ __ ]
yeah
he's
[ __ ] oh jay he's a bit of a creepy
dude isn't he yeah who would have
guessed wilden out yours truly
i don't know if you called decapitating
your ex-wife or the mother of your
children
and her friend who was visiting
um creep i mean let's not judge
it's perfectly normal behavior
wait this okay um
somebody's claiming they're the ones
that got
oj on twitter that sounds like a fake
call let's talk to them
what's their name there's so many lined
up
oh has a david dobrik pop-up story
okay i mean
that's interesting
no i don't see it
gabrielle
number
50
50 gabrielle worked on a documentary
producer who influenced o.j to join
twitter and also
a like call recruiter could skip it
sorry gabrielle
i'm trying to find a good one here
has a story about dressing up as ethan
and other uh universe characters and won
a costume contest
that's interesting
we skipped the whole reason though we
were even bothering to talk about uh
gta remaster what's the reason
we decided
to go ahead and um take a page from
rockstar and remaster the podcast oh
yeah so you're gonna like the results
this is only 60 bucks dlc you can
re-watch all of our old podcasts
remastered
here's me and ela looking kind of in our
more accurate right more it's more
lifelike it's more accurate it's more
higher pixels more vibrancy higher frame
rate yeah right
uh zach
here's remastered zach got a gnarly ass
widow's peak dude holy
count chocula
those eyes are real far apart too yeah
yeah inbred
here we go remastered a little bit
looking good very remarkable
extremely remastered
i don't really see the difference in
this one it's nice to finally get a real
representation of how you look in real
life
you know
this is what we see when we look at cam
yeah
av is batboy
uh sam and ian hansen's so funny she
looks like why they do sam like that she
looks like a different person man she
looks like a lady who does psychic
readings
yeah okay this ian's jaw is uh very
strong in this more resemblance to dan
with the beard move right
and of course dan
who's looking like a crackhead hobbit
dan is rolling
on yeah exactly
so yeah 60 bucks for all the back
catalog you can watch every episode
remastered
[Applause]
here is a uh
gta thread
something this is the best there's been
a lot of videos that came out of this
but this is my favorite don't look
behind you when first person on the quad
bike gets cursed
that's what it is
when you're riding a bike a quad bike is
it
if you look behind you to see who's
driving behind you this is what you see
that's
awesome that's so cool
i'm assuming you're just supposed to see
behind you not the dome yeah yeah
you have other videos yeah these are
great
yeah they're in the dark here
oh they are yeah
somebody said
all of our remasters look like people
from elder scrolls games
yeah
the oblivion npc character pack paper
man left me with number small change
hey get yourself a beer or something
oh my god
yo can you guys find like i want to do a
before and after because i don't think
the graphics are that different
oh they yeah
it's pretty significant and honestly the
um environments and stuff definitely do
look better it's mostly
and a lot of the main characters i guess
from what i understand they used an ai
uh to
upscale a lot of the models and
everything and then clearly didn't like
actually comb through it and fix a lot
of it that's what happened so that's
that's how you wound up with like that
bikini girl that's just looks like a
gorilla it's just like obviously super
[ __ ] up
here's more gta san andreas definitive
edition
this is a comparison video oh great okay
let's see
i mean this is just a cash grab right
especially they didn't even put the work
in
okay
yeah that looks better for sure but yeah
it's not that significant of a
difference
i saw a lot of people complaining about
the rain that it's overwhelming yeah
because this one oh i saw an image where
the rain you couldn't even see
ian just sent it oh yeah so
i saw people bitching about the rain
this is awesome watch this
imagine you're trying to play a video
game
isn't that awesome
i mean it is kind of interesting where
the rain actually blinds you because you
know it it could be like that right
it's you cannot see it there yeah i mean
he's right you shouldn't ride your bike
in that heavy rain less dangerous
i just sent a video that shows that the
water
in the game renders over the rain
interesting
i'm getting in the weeds here on this
gta sorry vertical birds
what it looks so stupid
it looks oh no it doesn't renders over
the water
that's the rain
oh my goodness what is nightmare it
reminds me of the cyberpunk game they
yeah it's kind of that level of uh
but the the difference is it's [ __ ]
20 year old game
well if you're gonna repackage and sell
20 year old game it better [ __ ] look
great right i mean for example demon
souls remake
unbelievable so good
sure right and
a much more niche thing than gta so here
is another moment
i told you he was crazy
and you jacked up
don't mind the helicopter
don't even bat an eye so realistic
actually i was
applauded for its realistic depiction of
life in
my l.a all right let's this actually one
this one interests me i've been
following this story
for a while
it's a friend of the show so i hate to
do it but i have to because it's just so
[ __ ] crazy big nick
friend of the show is maybe
it's i use you know i use it uh loosely
this [ __ ] been posting cringe
like i have never
seen
he's like a born a bit born again
christian but he has like the craziest
stakes he's basically super anti-vaxx
too by the way
yeah of course of course because jesus
and jesus as you know
doesn't believe in vaccinations
and actually you know what's crazy he's
found an audience like this video has
you know half a million likes
so people are down hashtag christian i'm
like you his tick tock stay up so well
yeah all glory with all things are
possible with god
god blocks us sister snipes so it says a
video of a woman rapping about her
private parts has 425 million views
while a video of it of him it's him by
the way yes
oh dude that's [ __ ] sad
while a dude rapping about god has 6.8
million views this is proof we are
living in dark times no it's it means
your music sucks dude that's that's the
only thing it's proof of
i mean i hate to say it bro but you kind
of brought it on yourself
but how the [ __ ] did half a million
people co-sign this
i'll tell you what those half a million
people that like that tick tock they
didn't go watch the video how many views
does have it's still i
it's in the dock it's right under this
you could just tell me
you know what here i'm gonna open it i'm
gonna open it i'm gonna be that guy
75 000.
okay so he got
got a few more views
here you want to hear this song let's
see what
i listened to it earlier and i gotta say
it's very bad oh i think you can see
it's a banger
okay terrible music
so it's sad music
he's like yo nobody likes my music
that's proof that we're in dark times
bro
dark times
[Laughter]
you know dude ela wouldn't let me order
pizza yesterday night
dark times bro proof that we're living
in dark times
at least she didn't go out without you
and she would never do that as long as
if mad as either has gone at me she
would never pizza cuck me there are
boundaries
in a trusting loving marriage that you
don't ever cross
facts
all facts no princess so here's the
video that he's mad doesn't have 300
million views
don't you [ __ ] claim me nick
i swear to god
yeah i'm the only one promoting your
[ __ ]
teaching
that points people away from the truth
tells people they don't need jesus and
you can get to him
here let's get some lyrics going
any other way
by the way i maybe i didn't explain
enough don't get mad at me for making
fun of him but he's like anti-vaxx he's
anti-gay horrible [ __ ] okay so we'll get
to all that
you have all that stuff maybe i don't
know if it's long enough the
big nickel judging by the chat our
audience is well aware okay good because
i don't want people like oh he's making
fun of his music
no he's like that's he's turned into
like a crazy religious bigot zealot
be scared to say it but i'm not afraid
of them frogs the only way progressive
christians need to change cause they
aren't saved need y'all to read
revelation 21 8 they
he said we need to read it
let's check it out
revelations 21 it's something about a
new heaven and a new earth
but the cowardly the unbelieving the
vile the murderers the sexually immoral
those who practice magic arts the
idol true
idolaters idol idolaters
i don't know how to say that
and all liars they will be consigned to
the fiery lake of burning sulfur this is
the second death why did he pick that
one isn't it like a thousand passages
like that in the bible
uh
this one seems particularly um
incendiary okay well there you go going
to hell
and he really does he does seem to have
an issue with the sexually immoral
yeah i want i i'd like to see his
homophobic stuff if you guys can find
that to put in the dark
but i'm here to fight the darkness yeah
it's time to make a change
[Music]
the antichrist spirits here i wish they
understood
[Music]
this should have 300 million views
dark times my friend
dark times when one of the biggest
artists in the world
with the best music producers in the
world and a huge massive fan base gets
more views than me
it's [ __ ]
dark [ __ ] dark times that's against
god i will say it's kind of a bop but it
is it's no chin up high though okay
all the time
[Music]
yeah exactly
let's skip that it goes
[Music]
[Music]
my soul is not his [ __ ] business
you ain't never seen heart look if you
saw like a child who was in distress
and you thought like maybe they were
being abused you would try to help
that's what he's doing except worse
because we're gonna die in damnation
forever
that's why you got to step in for you
save your soul dan i just got owned
more fox and logic
oh here is another big neck exposing
satan's secret in music [ __ ] yeah stay
away from secular music a lot of this
music secular music you mean anything
that's not christian related
you're blowing off the whole genre
of everything that's not christian
there's two types of music in the world
christian and secular
music for god and music for saiyan
frequencies to cause you harm as we know
satan was lucifer in heaven and he was
in charge of music we have to understand
that our spiritual enemy knows way more
about music than we do the satanic
illuminati bloodline family called the
rockefeller family actually carried out
a study on 440 hertz frequency this
programming frequency of music was shown
to i wonder where he found this was it
facebook
yeah probably this is actually this is a
big conspiracy theory that it doesn't
necessarily always have the um religious
angle although oftentimes it does
about
how
we tune all of our instruments to the
wrong frequency
and this
what did he say four four four six hertz
yeah because we tuned to 440 a440 uh 440
vibrations per second but that's against
god the
the real tuning that's right thank you
ian
the real tuning
if you want to be intelligent love is
saying he's not even showing the
rothschilds
or he's not showing the rockefeller
rockefellers yeah because that looks
yeah that's a roth ah he put the wrong
family man he's like another jewish
family
what's the difference they're all devils
good catch
yeah
that's awesome ready for i mean it just
shows how committed he is to deep
research
140 hertz frequency this programming
frequency of music was shown to cause a
lot of harm in people such as greater
aggression psychological agitation and
emotional distress a lot of big artists
in the music industry are actually using
this frequency to cause these problems
in your life check out a very very this
is like collective psychosis like that
this is like a schizophrenic paranoid
delusion if you think that music is
playing at a certain frequency to
scramble your brain if you told a
therapist that they would be like you
have paranoid schizophrenia and yet
there's like a mass paranoid
schizophrenia because facebook allows
this information to disseminate and
people are are like there's
mass psychosis i mean this is psychotic
popular rapper named xxxtentacion
talking about the same exactly
wait don't you don't you s
are dearly departed don't you say [ __ ]
the artists in the music industry are
actually using this frequency to cause
these problems in your life check out a
very popular rapper named xxxtentacion
talking about the same exact
are you thing fed if i play with those
frequencies right i can target certain
parts of the mind ecclesiastes 7 5 in
the bible
take it from xxs renowned researcher
better to hear the rebuke of the wise
than for a man to hear the song of fools
stay away from secular music because you
don't know the deep spiritual warfare
that it may be causing in your life so
he's playing at god's frequency is that
that means what is god's frequency
well
would you would you be surprised to hear
that uh they don't all agree on what the
what the proper frequency oh no yeah we
got to get on the same page at least
yeah uh
something which frequents which 32
i know uh dimebag dale from pantera he
tuned to 427. his guitar we don't like
427. that's devil's frequency more
radical
uh more radical among middle a haters
insisted the true frequency should be
528 because it's of it's digital bio
holographic precipitation
crystallization and miraculous
manifestation of divining frequency
vibrations wow so which frequency was
that that's a 528 okay this is important
528. that would change
i mean would you like to hear it
oh my god
the holy spirit wait that doesn't sound
like one frequency
at all
this is the
the [ __ ] is this this is just a pad on
the side
if you just listen to a frequency just
be like
yeah exactly
[Music]
i need that sine wave baby
[Music]
here i'll play it for you
yeah oh that's not 528 that's not 528
that's that's not 528 all right kill it
[Music]
thank you
here's scientific proof the bible is
real
uh big neck continues
did you ever find any homophobia one i
found a screenshot one he deleted
his stuff off his tic toc i found it
here it is this is the goddamn it's a
nice tone
528 pure
beautiful
that's a nice tone
this is what i want to hear when i send
i feel my brain crystallizing
that doesn't sound good i think that's a
called bloody brain cancer
[Laughter]
you don't want your brain crystallizing
anyway here we go big nick very popular
tic toc sixty thousand likes i'm gonna
show you how science proves that stories
in the bible are real okay
[ __ ] me
science proves that stories in the bible
are real there used to be a city called
sodom and gomorrah this city was full of
sinners who would do the most wicked
things they even worshipped this demonic
deity called bal
god was so fed up with the city that he
reigned fire and brimstone upon
everybody this city has already been
found
however this group of explorers took it
one step further and actually went there
they got there and discovered sulfur
balls which comes from fire and
brimstone
i'm going to show you how oh it's proven
oh checkmate
checkmate atheist
checkmate atheists forever okay so his
more inflammatory ones he erased i guess
but it it is a it gives you an inside
sidelines probably
oh yeah definitely here's here's a
screenshot we found ain't no way i'm
ever referring to you as they them dog
just act normal right i remember seeing
this one
and i was like yo like i get like
i mean he said he was bullied in david
dobrik's group and it [ __ ] him up
so how you gonna come out here and [ __ ]
with these mark this other there's a
marginalized group
why are you gonna [ __ ] say that let's
be on jack to dude
like cool dude oh so you're the cool
dude now you're you're the bully now
nick
cool just act normal why don't you act
normal bro stop with all the [ __ ]
four this is 578 hertz that [ __ ] ain't
normal trust me it's very abnormal
hell no it's not
here's more there's so many good ones
keep looking guys because i love that
[ __ ]
here is we live in a musical society
imagine living in a society
i hear that we do live in a society i
know an imma have
and we live in it despite knowing that
[ __ ] crazy it's crazy
so here is the more of the format that
works
he just listens to sad music and looks
at the screen and says ariana grande's
song blasphemy
god
blaspheming god has millions of streams
oh no it's the same stick
meanwhile a christian rap album only has
thousands this speaks
about today's generation
bro it's [ __ ] ariana grande
my god
you're like an amateur [ __ ] rapper
this is not right it literally just
means that
you know just doing the thing where he's
like nick nick you know what it means
let's be honest
you know exactly what it means
your music sucks bro
that's it sucks ass
[Music]
that's like sad sap [ __ ] can we i wonder
if this song is not no whatever let's
not even risk it
kingdom of god let's look up this one i
want to see how many
oh
damn damn so [ __ ] up that people don't
stream his music but they listen to
ariana grande
let's listen to kingdom of god
kingdom of god big nuke
wait he changed the name of it to hope i
think
because when i typed it this came out
it's awesome
yo we are in dark times that this video
only has 160 000 likes
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah
ariana grande ariana grande crying and
[ __ ] right now yeah
[Music]
ten commandments throw it up jesus
christ
i guarantee you that this isn't just
guarantee you isn't just amazing
damn there's nothing you've been born
again for like a year or two
yeah yeah i'm not sure i believe a
couple of years
i don't need a fake love i just
theoretically need space
yeah yeah it could be
i don't know how you drop this he's
waiting way too deep with god at this
point
i don't think you can drop it you think
he's committed
[Music]
up next big nick live at kenneth
copeland ministries
that's the dream no more flying and
tubes full of demons for you
i'm trying my best to keep all this
control done living in sin it's time to
repent and get myself back on a road for
us jesus you know that he died for us
[Music]
there's warfare but i know
yeah the fact that this has um
170 000 is pretty good
for like christian
amateur christian rap
like i don't know that you should be
complaining about how dare you
the world being dark because you're not
getting more than ariana like that's
pretty good bro you should be happy with
that
i'm curious to look at more of his stuff
i like his music it's [ __ ]
interesting
here let's sort by popular
betrayed oh [ __ ] yeah
that sounds gnarly
170 000 likes
oh hell yeah
tripping acid
[Music]
that's so true yeah i mean why are you
complaining on tick tock this isn't your
path dude dude this isn't the path that
god has for you you think god's powers
are limited like how small is your god
that he can't make your [ __ ] pop off
trust me god wants already on
god wants ariana not you oh yeah he's
made the choice it's obvious
[Music]
that hoodie was kind of demonic i'm not
gonna lie
this whole thing is like a hellscape
right i'm gonna become one of those guys
on youtube
that like
looks for illuminati imagery and popular
but just only about big nick i'm just
gonna dedicate all my time
to just doing like two hour long youtube
video just convincing himself yeah i
think i think if like some big label
approached him you know he's full of
[ __ ] he's like oh you you're demonic i'm
not gonna sign with you they're like
they're like listen big nick we love
your music
we'll give you a huge contract exclusive
if you drop the christian [ __ ] i just
he'd be like [ __ ] jesus he'd think that
shouldn't run wake up y'all god gave us
immune systems for oh hey this is the
anti-akovich that's awesome god gave us
immune systems for a reason
would it surprise you to know nick that
the vaccine works in
uh collaboration with our immune system
that's why it works
so
because
you don't have to catch a virus because
god
uh apparently gave you an immune system
right
you [ __ ] weirdo
i don't trust the government neither
should you
guys wake up the devil is using this
virus to segregate the church from the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated okay
this is the devil's work god forbid they
sit in different aisles like bro they're
still doing church together
you wake up
and let's not forget that these shots
are not fda approved they're only
authorized for emergency use is that
part of jesus talking points or is he
that seems like a
that has nothing to do with jesus it's
kind of worrying me he's straying from
the path of god
you see if it was fda approved it would
have to go under testing right here but
since it's used for emergency use there
is no testing procedure we are okay uh
big neck phd it's been approved now so i
wonder if he got vaccinated
or if he just moved the goal post again
he's got a chart dude did you see that
yeah that shirt's pretty fire i got to
say
the tenth question scripture tells us
not to be deceived so i'm warning you
now do not let any man deceive you god
gave us immune systems for a reason
guys wait yeah so the
wake up sheep the immune system is
incredible you know if you want a reason
to believe in god it's amazing how we
can put in dead cells
that teaches our immune system how to
attack the virus when it comes in it's a
miracle that's a [ __ ] miracle bro not
getting sick and dying of the plague
that ain't no miracle
that's how you lose faith in god you say
how's this possible
how could god let 700 000 people die
you know
what the [ __ ] bro
it's like so stupid it's actually just
infuriating like you want to talk about
proof of god explain to a child how both
of her parents or his parents died of
covet another [ __ ] orphan
because they didn't get a vaccine
dumbass
proof of god
thank you
things christians should avoid
this is interesting this is good advice
uh take notes guys please
120 000 likes
cussing all righty [ __ ] you [ __ ]
listening to worldly music you [ __ ]
kidding me bro
worldly music
it's against god what does that even
mean like he's on that kanye beat he's
on the same way okay let me listen
because okay they say don't listen to
worldly music the bible was written in
like ancient
israel right supposedly in that area the
middle east
let's just go with it so you're talking
specifically about like
were unworldly music when the time this
was written was probably like arabic
uh arabic music
i think he just means pop music like as
we know it today is that what he means
yeah
worldly
were you thinking like world music like
well i'm assuming when they say don't
listen to worldly music it means listen
to what's local here that we know yeah i
think he
means it's the same meaning as uh when
he said secular music as opposed to
spiritual jesus jesus music music yeah
okay cool
killing it we've got actually some
really good ones coming up
um
owning the pro-choice libs
he's of course against abortion i've got
a lot of respect for gay lesbian people
that have the courage to come out
that oh this what's wrong with this
nothing it's from 2016. this is to show
a contrast of oh so 2016 it was cool to
be gay
and then
is there one that contrasts
that owning the libs pro-choice
abortion is healthcare
no
last time i checked murder doesn't start
with an h
okay you got us again
that's that's airtight
murder animals
here he goes on an anti-feminist rant
yeah the problem is he deleted all the
really inflammatory stuff but yeah or
got bopped off at tic-toc
spiritual and psychological warfare why
the feminist movement is demonic are you
serious
feminist movement you see the feminist
movement was actually funded by
luciferians that were working in the cia
and this was to make women think that
they are not equal to man where the
bible clearly states that men and women
are equal they just serve different
functions and purposes so the feminist
movement tells this lie that men are
better than look women and men are equal
they just gotta do what the [ __ ] i tell
them
they gotta serve their narrow purpose
that i defined for them
feminism is when no blow job
take it from tim pool
then women and women need to take back
their authority and they need to
dominate man in every aspect possible
but you see this goes against biology
and scripture the feminist movement
actually channels a demonic spirit
called the jezebel spirit which is a
very manipulative dominant spirit that
wants to completely dominate their
husband whereas the bible makes it very
clear that a woman must submit to their
husband the same way their husband
submits to christ so if you're a
christian okay that's cool so you say
hello to christ your wife stays loyal to
you
luckily for the husband nobody's asking
him to fellate them
that chain
that chain of authority is a little
broken
with this whole feminist movement i just
want to let you know you can't serve two
masters you have to make a decision if
you're going to serve god or if you're
in the source
what is the spiritual and psychological
warfare and these people that get so
deep in the bible it's just so
interesting to me like
how you can con like those people in
israel
who are these devout
torah
the government pays them to study they
don't have to serve in the military and
they spend all day reading torah and
it's like i don't know you can spend
your whole life in one book interpreting
reinterpreting a book that's by by you
know historical accounts mostly fiction
um
okay let's say it's a v let's say it's
real i mean
it's like
it's just how do you spend your whole
life rereading the same [ __ ] pages
and trying to extract meaning like
people have been studying this book for
2000 years you don't think they've
figured it out by now we don't need more
bible research
we don't
people have read that book enough dude
it's you know what i'm saying it's done
it's played out bible's played out it's
so [ __ ] played out
move on here's a trump tick tock which
we love
you know we stand a moral king like
trump i'm the good christian boy
first president ever to acknowledge
needed christ you still need help
from the boss
you know we need help you know donald's
an atheist right
donald doesn't give a [ __ ] about
christianity
uh he just wants your vote
[Applause]
we need help
[Applause]
so powerful man yeah we need help it's
all right to say now they'll criticize
me for that how dare he say that
how dare he say that now i'll say it
this is so cheesy what is this reaction
football i'll say well that's 60 000
watts you said to me the other day
you're the most famous person in the
world by far said no i'm not
no i'm not they said yes you are so now
he said who's more famous i said jesus
christ
well and also john lennon and uh mozart
and uh
hitler's probably more famous stalin we
like to troll
i mean these are dead people he's not
alive that's my point
everything you can do wait for him to
say big neck
big neck shout out
here's a wait oh and then that's funny
because before his conversion he was
against trump who voted trump shake my
head
wait no this is pro-trump he said donald
trump a piece of crap
so
shout outs
yeah he had a lot of really anti-semitic
stuff but it's gone
the trans thing was was very bad
let me just surf his tick tock
let's see let's find the pop the boppers
this one is three 3.3 million that's him
crying people don't watch his music
spurred all this this one has uh six
hundred thousand views from secular
music a lot of this music is actually
using free yeah we heard that one it was
good
street preaching the lord is close to
the brokenhearted and saves those that
are crushed in spirit anyone who's had a
broken heart anyone who's been feel like
their their spirit has been crushed
they've been through pain depression
they've been cheated on they've been
backstabbed because you know they've had
people abandon them with their life that
they grew up with
the wrong frequencies
when you have that broken heart it's
like what else is there you know i've
tried everything myself and i didn't
know what else there was in life until i
tried jesus you know and by the way just
to make clear i'm not if people want to
be
go good with jesus and it helps them in
their life i think that's fantastic
i love it if you found meaning in your
life through religion beautiful what
sucks is that it turned you into a
[ __ ] bigot anti-vaxx anti-trans
anti-gay you're just a bigot now dude
rotted your brain decision i ever made
it was a decision that's going to carry
me off from this life to the next okay
whatever
human pig hybrid interesting big nick
this is the reality for people who die
without jesus they go to hell and hell
is a real place what is the surrendering
let's see what the bible has to say how
[ __ ] up are you in the head you think
this is what hell is like dude
where did this video come from
are you seeing this yeah it is so
graphic i'm gonna have to skip that it's
just demons hacking you up to pieces and
just in a pool of blood and
yeah bro [ __ ] sick
mark 9 43 jesus says if your hand causes
you to stumble cut it up it is better
for you to enter life maim than with two
hands to go into hell where the fire
never goes off jesus isn't saying for
you to cut off your arm but he's saying
that this is a physical injury is a lot
less worse than the severity of eternal
destruction in health so what's the good
news in all this i'm glad you asked the
good news is that you can literally say
yes to jesus right now repent of your
sins and be saved me and gabe are going
to be preaching in downtown fort worth
at the yeah
yes
anyway
ah there it is
shout out big nick
shout outs big nick
i feel like we're missing some really
good ones here's one with one country is
doomed
it is doomed not just because of african
americans but because
by 20 that's going to be edited right
country
good luck with your new ship
cap cab ryan kavanagh this guy just
keeps getting weirder and weirder so now
he's he's arguing oh the love baited him
by the way
i mean this is ryan kavanaugh arguing
with people in the comments of instagram
about me
uh and love baited him uh
love said
ryan made some posts about personalities
i don't know love came in he said
there's some this is something i keep in
my mind every time i meet a person have
you heard about the sugma rule
ryan says he and ryan added you as
direct response he says i have the third
personality type love it and you said
sugg my dick
[Music]
yeah
thank you thank you i wish i said
is yeah but i just hit him with it
when
what
anyway
pretty good you baited him though and
here he is again someone just said
keemstar shut up and ryan goes what does
keemstar have to do with this that to me
proves that they've had interactions
like why else would he respond
he and the guy didn't even tag him he
tagged keemstar
he goes i wish h3 productions would stop
flooding my insta with his hate paid
posts and fake foot soldiers does he
have anything better to do with this
time bro i'm here working all day when
am i what am i uh getting a bond what do
you think we do for a living dude talk
to shoe nice i don't i don't know how to
do that [ __ ]
i think there really was a self report
that is was such a weird comment yeah
yeah it is well we know for sure
allegedly for sure allegedly
allegedly for sure
allegedly we don't know what i'm saying
is we know for sure that it's alleged it
is for sure it is for sure
confirmed that it is for sure allegedly
parties by the way i legitimately we're
for sure election show ethan but uh
another one of those uh
people that work the uh the like farms
reached out to me oh for real said they
also got ryan cavanaugh's stuff
so that's two it's two ledgers we are
for sure alleging that ryan buys
bots he is a ledger so it's funny that
he accused me of doing that damn
anything better to do clearly i'm not
engaging with him you are though look at
you
and even though he is lying about me
suing him i have never
sued him nor am i the ceo of triller nor
do i control triller bro you're such a
[ __ ] weird liar
like not the ceo of triller that's
actually true wait i saw i i saw him say
i watched it in an interview they
introduced him controls trailer but he's
not the ceo
if you look it up right now at some
other dude okay i saw an interview where
they introduced him as the ceo of
trailer but he has a controlling
interest and every article you read
is like a [ __ ]
thing for sure
he's just
ryan i think he's the ceo of the parent
company
yeah so everything he does has to do
with triller his trailer fight club how
trailer became ryan cavanaugh's big
comeback why are you lying you freak
trump trailer and the return of ryan
cavanaugh wow
it's almost like they go hand in hand
some dude named mike liu is the ceo wait
so i think this is the one where he
introduced him as a ceo damon martin mma
fighting here with the ceo of triller
the man
ladies and gentlemen he interviews
introduced as the ceo of triller and
guess what
[Music]
between a pair of ufc legends anderson's
looking
no correction yeah he the man introduced
him as ceo of trailer you [ __ ] creep
yep you liar [ __ ]
clearly not engaged yeah
clearly not engaging with him even
though he's lying about me suing him
[ __ ] you're such a liar you're
literally named in the lawsuit that it's
defamation that we said you look like
harvey weinstein why why is that in the
lawsuit would you like to explain how's
that defamation ryan if you're not
involved in this lawsuit
freak
even though he's lying about me suing
him i have not ever sued him nor am i
the ceo of trailer nor do i control
trilla liar he's about to get slapped so
hard by the legal system for what he's
doing he won't know what hit him okay
let's see
we'll see we'll see who gets there'll be
a slap all right yeah
an anti-slap exactly
did you see ryan's response to love
he responded to this my dick yeah he did
oh it's in the chat discord wait not
what we just read were you like zoned
out again
oh yeah thank you very much yes so he
says
and then again at love of course the
rude comment comes from a
self-proclaimed h3 bot is that proof
he's a fan of the show
no no i don't know or is that what he
actually is
i think he's he's just calling everyone
who leaves a comment a bot i know it's
just but that's awesome it seems like
he's a fan
profile
so
you tell me who's got time you're
clicking on all the haters profiles
you didn't want me or anything
why that weirdo
you're not blocked
yeah
i think he kind of liked it honestly
it was the first real interaction he
died
he must have like a uh all the rest of
his comments are bots
it's the only non-bot in it yeah it was
like he must have a like
um
like a slave kink or like a pun
he's got a kink where he gets dominated
he's the oh like a humiliation yeah
exactly he has a he has a humiliation
fight yeah maybe that's possible that's
the only thing to explain this is
speculation
i mean a guy a guy like this definitely
likes his [ __ ] stump stomped on by the
edge of a stiletto definitely maybe
we're speculating
by the way look at that like dislike
ratio let me help out a little bit i'm
gonna come
and then here again in the description
triller co-founder ryan cavanaugh right
did he co-found it it says here it's a
ceo and co-founder i mean what the [ __ ]
you want from me bro
top comment is this the guy that was
accused of running a ponzi scheme by his
ex partner yes it was
wow i can't believe this guy's running
trailer he can't even pay his nanny good
observation
who refused to pay their nanny who faked
me too accusations against their own
executive triller was launched in 2015
15 by co-founders david lieberman and
sammy rubin
he is not the founder of triller there's
so much [ __ ] like disinformation
about
trailer out there it's crazy and he i
mean like you said he didn't correct him
exactly he he's the face of chiller
let's face it
yeah in 2019 ryan cavanagh's proxima
media made a majority investment
and yeah he he he's
he's not necessarily the ceo but it's
his
show
the triller show who refused to pay
their nanny who faked me two accusations
against an executive who was accused by
experience ponzi scheme ryan cavanaugh
yes ma'am
yes sir it literally says on his youtube
channel that he's the co-founder
okay thank you
ryan cavanaugh you stupid [ __ ] don't
you dare defend me in your comments
let's go to his see i can't even get to
his youtube channel it's all us
wait here's a okay here he is i thought
that was harvey i swear to god
um
i really did
brian this is his channel confirmed we
know this is his channel here's the
description he wrote ryan cavanaugh is
an la based entrepreneur film industry
veteran that's a nice way of saying a
bankrupted and ruined [ __ ]
failed businessman
a philanthropist
and co-founder of triller [ __ ]
wrote that yeah i think he
this is on techcrunch which is pretty
reliable about like tech news and stuff
and they
say co-founder
david lieberman well ryan's saying he's
the co-founder
yeah he's not mentioned in this article
and this was this is an article from
2016. ryan didn't become involved until
2019 so i don't know
what he found it exactly
he found it that if he starts [ __ ] with
me he's going to [ __ ] catch these
hands
easy
metaphorically metaphorical hands and
the court of law and minecraft
yeah so ryan keeps [ __ ] up you know
he's trying he's trying to
talk [ __ ] he's trying to lie about me
and most of all he's paying people he's
allegedly paying people
to write mean comments about me
specifically
in his instagram comment section it
doesn't get better than that folks
does not
get better than that
yeah but his linkedin says that he
founded triller fight club okay as their
boxing division and he's listed as the
principal for triller from 2019 on yeah
he didn't [ __ ] found triller like why
does he say that because it's it's still
on valor he likes it he's stolen you're
right he uses it when it makes him sound
important and then when he's getting
sued he he says i have nothing to do
with triller right to try to make it
look like i'm lying like you can't have
your cake and eat it too just own that
you are the co-founder of a app that is
going to [ __ ] make you bankrupt twice
over
what would uh
what would y'all rule call that
all right how long we've been going
we're coming up on three hours pretty
soon i'm having a lot of fun here today
i'm all [ __ ] up on benadryl
well my face is messed up is there uh
food here
a few minutes away
let's see if there's anything else we
can throw up here in the meantime elon
musk i'm so [ __ ] over this guy
you know got a lot of balls dude
we must demand that extremely wealthy
pay their fair share period i keep
forgetting you're still live he said
it's like awesome epic means bro
the best response i saw of this is elon
musk talking to his newborn baby
while he's doing epic my favorite was uh
a tesla to a person in a crosswalk
love that
you know elon musk making all this
hubbub that he like paid five billion in
taxes
okay
five percent of 300 is
uh about five percent one and a half
percent
five percent means everything i pay 50
[ __ ]
again i hate to to denigrate the
[ __ ] because we love them but
it's actually an abs job description as
tim paul inquired
we call him abc
you know what c stands for
[ __ ]
is that where you were
yes dan you're applying yeah
thank you dan thank you yeah clock abc
always be caulking i don't know
clucking
like a chicken head that's what they're
saying always be clucking
oh
god we'll come back
i don't know what's your take on this i
mean he's just such a douche sucks
you're the richest man in the world
posting epic memes on twitter trying to
be relatable and by the way bernie
sanders like he's a [ __ ]
he deserves a little respect
i mean
i mean elon can be a dick if he wants to
be a dick and
you know
whatever
i doubt it i doubt it bothered bernie as
much as it did
bernie's a king he doesn't probably not
even on twitter that's like some [ __ ]
intern that's tweeting that so
i wish bernie would come back on him
like aoc would have
clap back epic clapback
alive and still selling his snake oil
from one of his four houses to 20 year
old social studies majors
uh
he hit him with that crying laughing oh
i am crying rolling emoji rolling on the
floor
someone else the federal budget deficit
is 2.7 trillion guys this is pretty
[ __ ] the pay your fair share thing is
kind of a distraction because you can't
find 2.7 million in revenue you know why
we can't find 2.7 million because people
like elon musk are not paying their
taxes how is he co-signing this it's
like
this is like high-level lobbying that
the koch brothers do by him just
tweeting he's literally convincing broke
[ __ ] destitute hopeless people that
not taxing elon musk is in their
interest how's that possible
just because elon musk can't
single-handedly pay off 2.7 trillion
dollars in debt that we shouldn't
[ __ ] think about taxing him is insane
it's actually insane
uh
[ __ ] you dude
yeah we wouldn't be in so much debt if
you and all your contemporary
billionaires were actually paying their
tax imagine that
i think it's only fair that bernie
sanders supply an internalized list to
elon musk and all tax-paying citizens
explain where the government intend to
allocate his 15 billion
wasteful
what does that got to do with elon sure
i would like a breakdown too elon still
needs to pay his [ __ ] money just
because i don't like that my taxes go to
you know afghanistan doesn't mean that i
get to dodge paying my 50 in taxes
the same rules have to apply to elon
musk
and then of course elon being a pathetic
[ __ ]
he's just trying to convince all these
stans that he doesn't need to pay taxes
he gives them some thumbs up even though
this point has nothing to do with the
elon paying taxes at all
he's such a disappointment i used to
like him
you know
makes it hard to support him
i guess that's it
that's it
any of these tick tocks worth reviewing
and whatever not really i gotta pee
well it was a great show guys a few
things remember teddyfresh.com black
friday sale is live and roaring
uh looney tunes this thursday 10 a.m
uh members please consider becoming a
member we love our members we love our
members
videos a day early and an exclusive bts
every week the last one did great on
people loved it yeah
thank you guys thank you maybe
and hopefully more to come so
please consider being a member thank you
you want to read out some super chats or
anything before we go down
sure
let's see
let's see
uh abc always be cooking there you go
always be cocky huh um
let's see
this was about big nick what frequency
are big nick's songs
is there a way to analyze oh interesting
can we is there a way to do that
zach i mean yeah
we pull it in
yeah frequency somebody donated 50 bucks
and said i was unemployed for a while
after being laid off my saddest loss was
my h3 membership i now have my dream job
and i'm celebrating by being a member
again cheers to you guys for getting me
through this tough line thank you thank
you juana
thank you thank you thank you thank you
love you and love
there was a couple other here let me
scroll up a little bit
because there was a couple big boys that
i wanted to read out
uh
jake donated a hundred dollars
dearest papa this is my second 100
donation wow
almost as much as you graciously have
give gave me oh
oh wait
jake
didn't we we gave him money for
something
we gave him money
yeah was he the photographer oh he's
literally saying i gave him money yes
right okay i'm on tour with curtis
connor right now
right right right okay i remember this
story
he was a caller that got
screwed oh he got scammed by yeah and
you ended up giving him the money who
scammed him it was the demilios right oh
the demilious [ __ ] him and i gave him
a thousand bucks that's right shout out
not the name like familiarity bro shout
outs
uh i'm gonna email you again and again
for an opportunity to work together okay
keep it i guess keep going i'll take bts
voters for free by the way um well thank
you for the donation jake ethan is the
michael jordan of podcasting this will
be known as the flu podcast
right michael and scotty baby
help me
oh i wish i had seen this when we were
talking about nick nick is literally
wrong he's saying sodom and gomorrah was
a city it was two cities he isn't even
reading the bible well that's a good
point
very well stated
here's um
ethan this is this is really interesting
avex donated five dollars said did you
know
that the ceo of triller ryan cavanaugh
was accused by his ex-partner running a
ponzi scheme okay wait let me look into
that because i had heard that before but
i'm not totally sure on the details of
that
so
if everyone could just google
ryan kavanaugh ponzi scheme spend some
time on the website
that'd be good
that'd be fantastic i appreciate that
five dollars from andrew dan the type of
guy to pretend to know nothing of taylor
swift but cries at every song
yeah you got me big swifty over here
he has a point something interesting the
type of guy to tell kids to get off
their phones and go outside
interesting what do you think about that
i gotta say
i i don't say this to be a hater
but like in all of these
when this was like a meme on the channel
and everybody was like a b the type of
guy
ethan the type of guy
i love it i love it mine suck you guys
don't know like i've literally seen like
one that was like made me laugh i was
like oh they got me well let's see
you're there i'm not gonna
i'm really not i i would never i'd spend
all of my time inside by the way i just
got a donation from holly uh
thank you for the donation she said
um big nick in the bible it says no
markings on your body
big nick has tattoos oh [ __ ] he's going
to hell there's a there's a video where
he addresses his tattoos or he dresses
why they're
a sin
i could find that oh so he acknowledges
sin yeah he acknowledges it okay good so
he's living with sin like the rest of us
loser
people saying that that's the joke it's
not though because sometimes it's like
like ethan floating through the air
on the on the smell of a pie i mean that
like that i've seen him do that like
that's funny
that like nails it
i'm trying to think of a good dan is the
type of guy right now
dan the type of guy to get
made at bad type of guy comparisons
i think your typo kind of [ __ ] that
one up sorry kevin
um
ethan do you still have your royce if so
do you have the black badge no i don't
the black badge is like
some even crazier version of the colon
which i don't know what's the difference
but it's like six hundred thousand
dollars
i just got a used one off the lot i just
went there with trisha for that one
video and bought got uh at least one off
the lot that is used it's a black one
and uh yes it's my it's my drive it's my
car it's my my commute
i had another car that i returned
because i was like i don't want to have
two cars i don't have like 10 cars in my
driveway like tricia
so i returned them all
dan the type of guy to say he's not that
guy oh there you go i'm not that no
you're not
oh
but i literally just did
and this was much earlier they didn't
say this in reaction to here's what i
just did is the type of guy who sit when
he pees
that's interesting right
dan the type of guy to secretly like the
big bang theory oh [ __ ] no that's com
that never ever ever
hmm
you sure at least the sit wallet the pee
thing is at least that one's funny here
andrew donated dan the type of guy to
order and thai food on a saturday night
with his cat instead of fully sending it
instead of what
i guess going on partying
half center oh instead of full sending
i mean that one's fairly accurate
dan let me think here we go
anyways let's [ __ ] wrap this [ __ ] up
there's food i gotta pee so bad we got
lunch
well thank you guys all for being here
it's been an awesome monday as usual
uh we'll be back
as usual
on thursday wednesday for members
there's a new leftovers up if you're
looking for something to watch in the
meantime take a look at that
came out yesterday
and uh until we see you next time peace
and love
from the h3 podcast
[Music]